SOMEONE TO GO AHEAD AND GET.
STARTED I REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYONE BEING HERE THIS
MORNING- THIS IS AN APPOINTED
PROFESSIONAL HEARING ON
AGRICULTURE EXPORTS AND- A
CALIFORNIA SPORTING GOODS
MOVEMENT SELECTED THANK- MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
DONALD IN IN HIS STAFF ALONG
WITH OUR ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE-
OUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR WORK I AM PUTTING THIS
HEARING TOGETHER. AND BEFORE WE
BEGIN I WANT TO QUICKLY ADDRESS
SOME LOGISTICAL ITEMS FOR THIS
HEARING- I LIKE TO NOTIFY THE-
THE PUBLIC- AND- AND EVERYONE
HERE THAT- THIS. HEARING HAS A
THEY GAVE A SHARP STOP AT ELEVEN
SO IF WE CAN LIMIT. COMMENTS I
KNOW. SOME OF US LIKE TO BE LONG
WINDED IF WE COULD- RESIST THAT
AND ASSUME THAT BE FANTASTIC. I
AM FOR THOSE THAT ARE HERE IN
THIS ROOM FOR. THE PARTICIPANTS
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC PLEASE
KNOW THAT THROUGHOUT THIS
HEARING. FACE COVERINGS MUST BE
WORN AT ALL TIMES- AND ALL
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC MUST MAINTAIN
AT LEAST SIX FEET OF PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
FACE COVERING PLEASE LET US KNOW
AND I'M SURE WE CAN- GET ONE FOR
YOU- AND DO A PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN REQUIREMENTS THERE IS LIMITED
SEATING AVAILABLE. IN THIS AREA.
AND WE WILL BE. MONITORING THE
CAPACITY THROUGHOUT THE-
HEARING. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS I NEAR THE
END OF THE HEARING WILL BE
SHOWN. TO VIEWERS ON SCREEN.
THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING IT'S
ALSO- IT'S POSTED ON ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IS ALSO WELCOME TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS TO THE
ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE- THE
COMMITTEE THROUGH EMAIL. AT AG
ARE I. DOT COM- COMMITTEE AT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DODGY OVIH. THE
EMAIL ADDRESS CAN ALSO BE FOUND
ON OUR WEBSITE. IN ORDER TO-
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARING
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC EYE AND
FROM OUR PAELISTS AS POSSIBLE-
WE WILL NOT. PERMIT US TO
CONDUCT THAT- THAT DISRUPTS THE
DISTURBANCE OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF. THIS
HEARING. AGAIN WE HAVE COME
TOGETHER THIS MORNING TO DISCUSS
AND LEARN. ABOUT AGRICULTURAL
EXPORTS- AND CALIFORNIA'S PORTS
AND GOODS MOVEMENT. IT'S NO
SECRET THAT OUR PORTS AND
SHIPPING CRISIS IS DISRUPTING
THE SUPPLY CHAIN ACROSS NUMEROUS
INDUSTRIES. NOW FOR OVER A YEAR-
ARE STATES PORTS HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGED WITH UNLOADING
OSINBAJO NECKS WORKER AND
TRUCKER SHORTAGES. AND A LACK OF
EQUIPMENT. THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF FACTORS THAT- HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THESE BACKLOGS IN
THESE CONGESTIONS COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. INCREASES IN ONLINE
SHOPPING. LABOR ISSUES AND SOME
DISAGREEMENTS AND CERTAINLY MORE
AT THROUGHOUT PORT OFFICIALS
STATE AND- FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES THEY HAVE MADE SOME
TREMENDOUS EFFORTS TO REDUCE OUR
THESE BACKLOGS AND THESE
CONGESTIONS. A STATE
POLICYMAKERS WE NEED TO
CERTAINLY- UNDERSTAND AND BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW TO AVOID A
RECURRENCE OF THESE ISSUES. AS
WELL AS THE SHORT AND LONG TERM
CONSEQUENCES THAT POOR
CONGESTION HAS HAS AND WILL HAVE
ON ON- OUR STATE'S AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY. CALIFORNIA AG INDUSTRY
IS A GLOBAL LEADER THAT TOTALED
FORTY NINE POINT ONE SOME
BILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND
TWENTY ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
IN AG EXPORTS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
. AS OF TODAY WE KNOW THAT THE
CURRENT- CONGESTION CRISIS HAS
HAD A CRIPPLING EFFECT ON OUR
STATE'S AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY. AS
FARMERS HAVE AND CONTINUE TO
FACE SIGNIFICANT LOSS EXPORT
OPPORTUNITIES. NEW RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT FROM MAY TO
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR PORT AND
SUPPLY CHAIN CONGESTION. COST
CALIFORNIA FARMERS APPROX ME TWO
POINT ONE BILLION. IN AG
EXPORTS. A. LOSS MORE COSTLY
THAN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN US
CHINA TRADE WAR. ULTIMATELY THIS
DAMAGES OUR STATE'S ECONOMY AND
PARTICULARLY OUR SMALL FAMILY
OWNED FARMS AS WELL AS OUR
REPUTATION ABROAD. IF WE DO NOT
TAKE PRO ACTIVE MEASURES. THAT
TO STOP THIS FINANCIAL BLEEDING
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY WILL CONTINUE TO BEAR
THE BRUNT OF THE COST OF HIS
ONGOING PORT CONGESTION. AS WE
ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
WORLDWIDE LEADER AND THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY AND
INDUSTRY THAT WORKS- TO PUT FOOD
ON THE TABLES ACROSS THE GLOBE
AND ULTIMATELY MAINTAIN THE
WORLD FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN. AS
POLICYMAKERS WE MUST LOOK AT
WHAT ACTIONS WE CAN TAKE IN THE
SHORT AND LONG TERM. TO ENSURE
FARMERS HAVE THE RESOURCES JUST
TO SURVIVE THIS ECONOMIC
CHALLENGE AND KEEP CALIFORNIA AS
THE WORLD AGRICULTURAL LEADER I
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS HEARING
TODAY AND WOULD LIKE. TO INVITE
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
DONALD TO MAKE SOME REMARKS I
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR INTEREST IN
THE JOINT HEARING ON
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS AND
CALIFORNIA ISSUES. APPEAR SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE PORCH AND GOODS
MOVEMENT- THANK EVERYBODY FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD. NOT ANSWER
AGUIAR-CURRY SOME OF THE BOND
WOMAN- OVERWHELMINGLY
AGRICULTURAL. HAVING DISTRICTS
QUITE FRANKLY. ALL THE MORE I
MEAN WE DON'T HAVE THAT AND OR-
BUT- THIS ISSUE HAS TO BE
CREATED AND CERTAINLY WE WILL
DISCUSS TODAY. THE DISTRIBUIDORA
LOVED EACH OTHER LOOKING FOR
COMPLEX NOT TOO LONG AGO. IN
NOVEMBER THE SELECT COMMITTEE
HELD A HEARING ON THE POOL GOODS
MOVEMENT CRISIS AND ITS IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA'S PORTS AND SUPPLY
CHAIN THE IMPACT FOR MANY.
IMPACTS WERE NOT JUST ON IMPORTS
BUT THEY WERE ALSO ONE EXPLORE.
NOT EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT. WE ARE. STATE AND IT IS PROBABLY. THE
GROW WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO
CONGESTION AT OUR PORTS AND KEEP
GOODS MOVING. TODAY'S HEARING
WILL TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT ONE
COMPONENT OF OUR GOODS MOVEMENT
SYSTEM AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS KITA
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE BREAD
BASKET. OF THE NATION.
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE EXPORTS
HAVE GROWN SUBSTANTIALLY OVER
THE LAST DECADE- THE VOLUME WAS
HEAVY WHAT WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY PROBABLY IS PHILOSOPHY.
GETTING THAT STUFF OUT TO WHERE
IT IS TO LAND CONSUMERS LOOK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NAME KNOWING THEY
CAN EXPECT GREAT QUALITY FROM
OUR PRODUCTS CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY DEPENDS ON
ITS ABILITY. TO EXPORT GOODS
THROUGH OUR NETWORK OF PORTS IN
THE CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE ELEVEN PORTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN VARYING
SIZES. I REPRESENT THE TWO
LARGEST THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES
AND THE PORT OF LONG BEACH
TOGETHER THOSE SPORTS CHANNEL
ABOUT FORTY PERCENT. OF
CONTAINERIZED KARKAR GO ENTERING
THE COUNTRY IN ABOUT 3830% OF
CONTAINERIZED EXPORTS. WHEN OUR
PORTS AND SUPPLY CHAIN ARE
WORKING AS INTENDED THEY OFTEN
GO UNNOTICED. BUT NOW PEOPLE ARE
NOTICING FOR A VARIETY REASON
AGAIN NOT JUST ON IMPORTS BUT
ALSO ON EXPORTS. YEAH WE ARE IN
A MAY A MIST OF A MAJOR
DISRUPTION OF THE GLOBAL SUPPLY
CHAIN OUR PORT LEADERS ARE
RESPONDING TO THAT CRISIS THEY
DID NOT CREATE THAT CRISIS I
WANT TO UNDERLINE THAT BUT THEY
ARE RESPONDING- TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY TO. THAT CRISIS.
THERE'S A SHARP INCREASE IN
CARGO VOLUMES. IT IS CREATED
SIGNIFICANT JET SIGNIFICANT
CONGESTION WITH MORE SHIPS
SITTING OUT THERE- BASICALLY
FLOATING WAREHOUSES SUPPORT DR
FOR THE WAREHOUSES ARE FULL.
THERE'S SOME SHORT TERM
SOLUTIONS AND SOME LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS. TO THOSE ISSUES AND
NEARBY COMMUNITIES ARE
ABSOLUTELY IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
IN MY DISTRICT. AB AS DEMAND FOR
CONTAINER SPIKE AGRICULTURE
EXPORTERS FACED INCREASED
DIFFICULTY FINDING CONTAINERS OF
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT THAT
WAS THE- MOTHER DIFFICULTY WAS
ASSOCIATED NOT FIGHTING
CONTAINER AND EVEN THEN IF YOU
HAD A CONTAINER YOU MIGHT NOT
HAVE A CHASSIS TO PUT THAT CONTAINER SO
THEY AREN'T ALWAYS WELL
UNDERSTOOD THE ISSUES IT MIGHT
NOT EVEN BE SPACE AT THE DOCK IT
MIGHT BE YOU CAN'T GET A
CONTAINER FOR YOU CAN'T GET. HSE
TO MOVE THAT CONTAINER. THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF PROGRESS MADE IN
THE FEW MONTHS LAST FEW MONTHS I
WANT TO COMMEND- GENE SOROKA.
AND MARIO CORDERO FROM MY
DISTRICT THAT'S PART OF LONG
BEACH DIRECTOR IN PORT OF LA
DIRECTOR- IT. THOUGH THOSE
GENTLEMEN AND THEIR TEAMS HAVE
BEEN WORKING TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY TO RESPOND. TO THE CRISIS
OUR ROLE TODAY IS TO LISTEN.
LISTEN TO THE EXPERTS TO
DETERMINE WHAT WE CAN DO TO EASE
CONGESTION FOR A STATE
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS AND
STRENGTHEN OUR SUPPLY. CHAIN
WILL NOW GO TO PANEL ONE A GENE
SOROKA IS GOING TO BE OUR FIRST
PANELISTS- AND HE'S GOING TO-
SHARE SOME INFORMATION AND WE'LL
HAVE SOME TIME. FOR QUESTIONS
FROM HIM AND THEN HE WILL LEAVE
THE PANEL. OUR OUR FIRST PANEL
WILL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF HOW
THE GLOBAL CONGESTION CRISIS HAS
AFFECTED CALIFORNIA'S PORTS AND
THE IMPACT IT HAS HAD ON
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTERS ABILITY
TO GET THEIR PRODUCTS ON SHELVES
AROUND THE WORLD. FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME JEANNE SOROKA
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PORT OF LOS ANGELES WHO HE WHO
IS JOINING US. REMOTELY TO WRITE
AN UPDATE- MISTER STROKE AGAIN
WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS AFTERWARD
AND JUST FOR A LITTLE CONTEXT-
REPORTS DONE ON THE CHASSIS IS
THEY DON'T ON THE CONTAINERS.
AND THOSE ARE ALL THIRD PARTY
OPERATIONS SO IT'S NOT LIKE THE
PORK AND SAY HEY TAKE A CHASSIS
TO AN AGRICULTURAL- EXPORTER-
IT'S THAT'S NOT RALLY THE ROLE
OF THE PORTS THEY'RE MORE
THEY'RE MORE LANDLORDS BUT- THEY
ARE HELPING FACILITATE SOLUTIONS
TO DIFFERENT PROBLEMS. IMPACTING
THE PORTS WELL THAT WILL GO TO
MISTER- GENE SOROKA. REPORTER
LOS ANGELES. THANK YOU CHERYL
DONALD LAND SHARE RIVAS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
EUGENE D. SOROKA ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE PORT
OF LOS ANGELES AND I APPRECIATE
YOU INVITING ME TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
HEARING. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA CAN POSITION ITSELF
TO REASSERT TRADE LEADERSHIP AND
CONVERTED SUPPLY CHAINS INTO A
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE WHILE
SUPPORTING OUR VITAL AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY. THREE MESSAGES I'D
LIKE TO BRING TO YOU TODAY HOW
WE GOT HERE WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN THE FUTURE
THIS ALL STARTED BACK IN THE
FIRST QUARTER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WITH THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON.
AND TRADE POLICIES WE BEGAN TO
IMPLEMENT NEW POLICY INVOLVING
TERRORISTS ON IMPORTED GOODS
FROM CHINA AND WERE MET WITH
RETALIATORY CHAIR CHERUBS. BY
THE PRC. I'M MAINLY AGRICULTURE
AND MANUFACTURING PRODUCTS FAST
FORWARD TO THE FOURTH QUARTER OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE HAD
BROUGHT IN SO MANY IMPORTS AHEAD
OF TERROR OF SIN TAXES ON
AMERICAN COMPANIES THAT WE
STOPPED IN FACT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES BUSINESS DROPPED BY 16%
IN THE FOURTH QUARTER OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN BECAUSE WE HAD
IMPORTED ALL THAT WE CAN HANDLE
AND WE BEGAN TO SEE. THE IMPACT
ON EXPORTS AND SPECIFICALLY
GROWERS PRODUCERS RANCHERS
FARMERS AND THEIR PRODUCTS THAT
NEEDED TO GO OVERSEAS THEN IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY COBIT
NINETEEN HIT THE MANUFACTURING
SECTOR IN CHINA AND THE CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN THE CHINESE
ECONOMY I LIVED IN CHINA FOR
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS I STILL
MULTI TREMENDOUS REAL SHIPS- AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT MAKES THEIR
BUSINESS CHECK. YEAH THROUGH ALL
OF THIS COBIT NINETEEN CAME TO
OUR SHORES IN THE MONTH OF MARCH
AND WE SHUT DOWN OUR ECONOMY
WITHIN THE FIRST TEN DAYS SO FOR
ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS. WE'VE
LIMITED IMPORTS COMING INTO THE
U. S. AND WE'RE HIT WITH BOTH
COBIT NINETEEN AND THE TELLER OF
POLICIES THAT IMPACTED UNITED
STATES EXPORTS. MOVE FORWARD TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE MOVED MORE
CARGO THAN ANY PORT IN THE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE TEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION CONTAINER UNITS
THE LARGEST AMOUNT OF CARGO BY
ANY MEASURE AND 13% GREATER THAN
OUR BEST YEAR ON RECORD. WHICH
DEVIOUSLY WAS HELD IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MORE JUNE UP
HERE FOR THE DOCKWORKERS
TRUCKERS WAREHOUSE WORKERS ONE
IN NINE JOBS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION'S IMAGE. IS
IMPACTED BY THIS PORT AND ONE
FIFTY TWO NATION WIDE. DURING
THIS TIME WE SAW A DECLINE IN
EXPORTS THIRTY FOUR OF THE PAST
THIRTY EIGHT MONTHS HAVE
WITNESSED THOSE DECLINES MAINLY
ON THE HEELS OF THAT TRADE
POLICY AND SPECIFICALLY WITH
RESPECT TO RECYCLABLES WHETHER
IT BE WASTE PAPER PLASTIC METAL
SCRAP. THOSE CARGOES WERE
DECLINING AT THE SAME TIME AND
CORRESPONDINGLY THE
REPOSITIONING OF EMPTY
CONTAINERS BACK TO ASIA TO CATCH
THE NEXT ROUND OF IMPORTS QT
UNITED STATES INCREASED AN
INCREASE LAST YEAR IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. BY 40% ALL
REMARKABLY AGRICULTURE EXPORTS
HAVE BEEN FLAGGED WE'VE NOT FALL
OFF THE CLIP BLADE WE HAVE WITH
OTHER COMMODITIES. REMAINING
FLAT I BELIEVE THERE'S MUCH MORE
TO DO AND LOOKING AT THIS
SEGMENT IT VIEW OF AG EXPORTS WE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WITH THE
TRADE GAP WIDER THAN EVER. FOR
EVERY FIVE CONTAINERS THAT COME
INFORMATION ONLY ONE GOES BACK
OUT WITH AN AMERICAN EXPORTS THE
BALLOT OR ARE EMPTY REPOSITIONED
55% OF OUR TRUCK GATES GO UNUSED
EVERY DAY AND WE HAVE AN
OVERHANG OF 30% CAPACITY. WITH
OUR RAIL SERVICE GOING OUT OF
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES SO THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
FORWARD WE'VE BEEN WORKING AT
THE FEDERAL STATE LOCAL LEVEL
THE CONVENE PARTIES AND
IMPORTANTLY INCLUDING THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. MAY WHOSE
LEADERS ARE DOMICILED IN ASIA
AND EUROPE OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED
STATES AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO CREATE
THOSE SOLUTIONS WE'VE LOOKED AT
DOING THE BASIC BLOCKING AND
TACKLING IMPROVING TRUCK TURN
TIMES THE VISIT. OF THOSE
TRUCKERS IMPROVING THE RAIL
CAPACITY AND HOW WE MOVE CARGO
IN AND OUT THERE BUT NO SHORTAGE
OF NEWS HELICOPTERS CIRCLING OUR
PORT WITH ALL THE CARGO COMING
IN BUT I WILL REPORT TO YOU.
THAT WE MOVED OUT MORE CARGO
THAN EVER BEFORE RETAIL SALES
FOR THE HOLIDAY SEASON WERE UP
EIGHT POINT 5% ADD FOR THE
NATION WE ECLIPSE THE BEST MARK
EVER. IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES WITH SALES TO THE
AMERICAN CONSUMER NOW IT'S OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PICK UP ON WHAT
WE WANNA DO EXPORT LICENSE
SPECIFICALLY. FOR THE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY. IN
ADDITION TO WORKING ON THAT
LATENT CAPACITY WE OF WORKED
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE WITH THE
AGENCIES IN WASHINGTON WITH
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S OFFICE THE
ELECTED AND APPOINTED. APPOINTED
OFFICIALS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO KEEP THESE
CONVERSATIONS GOING AND MOVING
FORWARD WITH OUR SUPPLY CHAIN.
PROPOSALS NUMBER ONE IS THAT
SINCE WE PROPOSE THE THREAT OF A
FEET ON AGING IMPORT CONTAINERS
BACK ON OCTOBER TWENTY FIFTH.
WE'VE MOVED OUT 71% OF THAT
CARGO THAT WAS SITTING HERE IDLE
WITH JUST THE THREAT OF A FEAT
WE NEVER COLLECTED A NICKEL BUT
WE GOT PRODUCT TO MARKET MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE GOT PARTS TO
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES. WE GET
APPARATUS TO OUR HOSPITALS AND
WE GOT FOLLOW THE PRODUCTS TO
THE RETAIL SALES GROUPS. WE HAVE
ALSO CALLED FOR OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS. A NATIONAL AND STATE
EXPORT POLICY WE NEED TO GET
FARMERS AND MANUFACTURERS BACK
IN THE INTERNATIONAL GAME.
REMOVING THE US TRADE
IMPEDIMENTS THAT ARE ALL HAD
POINTS TO IS THE STRENGTH OF THE
U. S. DOLLAR IS IMPORTANT ON SO
MANY LEVELS ECONOMICALLY BUT-
IT'S A PROBLEM CHEAPAIR TO
BRAZIL WITH SOYBEANS AND OTHER
TRADING NATIONS BECAUSE THEIR
EXCHANGE RATES. ARE MORE
COMPETITIVE THAN OURS BUT WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
PUTTING OUR EXPORTERS IN
POSITION TO BE COMPETITIVE AND
IN ADDITION TO SO MUCH ELSE THAT
WE'RE DOING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS ACT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL JUST NOW LAW. AS A
PORTION SEVENTEEN BILLION U. S.
DOLLARS TO PORTS AND WATERWAYS
AND IT WILL HELP US HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN HAND
SYSTEM RESILIENCY. AND START FOR
THE FIRST TIME EVER WHAT WE CALL
CONNECTING CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
BRINGING THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS
WELL AS THE INLAND EMPIRE IN
OTHER REGIONS CLOSER TO THE
WATERFRONT OF OUR PORTS.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S PROPOSED
BUDGET. DESIGNATE DESIGNATES TWO
POINT THREE BILLION U. S.
DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN
MUNICIPAL PORTS IT PASSED BY
THIS LEGISLATURE. THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING COMMITMENT COMBINED WITH
THAT SEVENTEEN BILLION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. REPRESENTS A
MONUMENTAL OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
PORTS ARE SUPPLY CHAINS GLOBALLY
AND OUR LEADERSHIP POSITION IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN IT ALSO
RECOMMENDS EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE ORGANIZING IN THE
DEPLOYMENT. OF ZERO EMISSIONS
TRUCKS EQUIPMENT AND CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FURTHER. OTHER
LINE ITEMS INCLUDE ONE HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
NATION'S FIRST AND ONLY TRAINING
CAMPUS FOR LABOR ACROSS THE
GOODS MOVEMENT SECTOR IN THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDING DIGIT IS.
THAT CALIFORNIA'S PORTS AS
ALWAYS I WELCOME ALL OF YOU TO
VISIT THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES AT
YOUR EARLIEST CONVENIENCE AND
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS MORNING TO
TESTIFY I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. GREAT
JOB THANK YOU MISTER SOROKA OF
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AGAIN I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS ISSUE. AND WE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENCE TODAY I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW THE PRESENCE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VIA PORT PORT. PADURA
MISTER V. THIS IS NEW NAME
MISTER VERY. SIMILAR FRIEDMAN IS
SIMILAR MATHIS. WHO IS THE CO
CHAIR OF THE AGRICULTURAL- AND-
SO- MAJORITY LEADER REYES MISTER
GIBSON IS ON THE LOWER RIVER
COVERS- AND SOON WILL COVER. I
ASSUME- THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES-
AND ANYBODY ELSE I KNOW MR JONES
SAWYER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENCE HERE TODAY SO WE HAVE A
GOOD GROUP HERE RARELY DO YOU
GET THIS MANY MEMBERS AT A- AT
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING WITH
THAT ARE THERE QUESTIONS FOR
MISTER SOROKA MISTER STROKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THIS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PRESENTATION WE SAW YOU LAST
TIME I BELIEVE IN THE FALL YOU
WERE HERE AS WELL- WHAT DO YOU
THINK IT HAS HASN'T WORKED. AND
WHAT DO WE NEED MORE- OF FROM
EXISTING OF THE STRATEGIES THAT
WE NEED TO HELP IMPLEMENT. TO
MOVE THE EXPORTS ALONG. WHAT IS
THE AND I'VE BEEN IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN FOR- FOR OVER THREE
DECADES AND I'VE NEVER SEEN
ALIGNMENT LIKE WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW. FEDERAL STATE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND WE AS THE LONE. PUBLIC
SECTOR CONVENER. OF THIS LARGELY
PRIVATE SECTOR SUPPLY CHAIN ARE
STARTING TO SEE SOME MORE
MATTER. IF WHAT WE'RE DOING. IT
THIS IS NOT ANY FAILURE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES OR ANY OF THE OTHER
TEN PORTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE WENT FROM ZERO TO
A HUNDRED. IN THE SUMMERTIME OF
TWENTY TWENTY BECAUSE OF THE
STRENGTH OF THE AMERICAN
CONSUMER WE COULDN'T GO TO BALL
GAMES ORMOVIES WERE WEREN'T
FLYING ON AIRPLANES ARE GOING TO
OTHER EVENTS WE WERE AT HOME
BECAUSE OF COVERT NINETEEN. AND
MA'AM I LIVED IN CHINA. DURING
SARS I SAW FIRST HAND WHAT A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC COULD MEAN AND
THIS WAS MULTIPLE TIMES WORSE
THAN ANYTHING WE'VE EVER
WITNESSED WE BOUNCE BACK BECAUSE
WEEKEND OUTINGS WERE NOW WE'RE
TRIP TO COSTCO OR TARGET. VERSUS
ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE COULD
POSSIBLY DO. AT THE SAME TIME
TRADE POLICIES NATIONWIDE
INHIBITED EXPORTS OF U. S.
PRODUCTS AND I KEEP IN TOUCH
WITH THE AMERICAN FARMER
NATIONWIDE FOR MY DECADES LONG
CAREER IN THIS INDUSTRY THE
PHASE ONE TRADE DEAL WITH CHINA
AS IMPACTED THE AMERICAN FARMER
UNLIKE ANYTHING WE'VE EVER SEEN
. HERE AT HOLMAN CALIFORNIA
WHETHER IT BE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OR OTHER LOCATIONS WE NOW
HAVE A VERY UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
WITH MORE VESSEL IN
INTERNATIONAL TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES THAN EVER BEFORE AND
MORE EMPTY CONTAINERS AT OUR
DISPOSAL TO PUT GOODS IN THOSE
BOXES AND MOVE THEM OVER STATES
SO IT'S TIME THAT WE LOOK AT
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CAN BRING. COALESCED WITH
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR FROM THE ELECTED AND
APPOINTED OFFICIALS AS WELL AS
HERE AT THE MUNICIPALITY IN LOS
ANGELES AND WITH THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AMERICAN
EXPORTERS I THINK AGRICULTURE
HAS TO BE FRONT AND CENTER BUT-
WHAT WE MUST DO. IS SHAVE OFF
ALL THE BELLS AND WHISTLES THE
FOLKS IN GENERAL HAVE A
REPUTATION THAT'S NOT SO GOOD IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN SECTOR WE'VE
GOT TO CHANGE THAT WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE THEM THE CUSTOMER OF
CHOICE. ADDITIONAL STORAGE IN
ORIGIN AND DESTINATION LOW
PRICES THAT'S A THING OF THE
PAST WE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET OUR PRODUCTS TO OVERSEAS
MARKETS AND BRING THAT PRIVATE
SECTOR SERVICE PROVIDER RATE
HERE BACK TO HOME IN CALIFORNIA
SO WE CAN MOVE MORE AG PRODUCTS
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
DAIRY FOODS ASSOCIATION THE
AGRICULTURAL TRANSPORTATION
COALITION. AND THE GREAT WORK OF
OUR OWN SECRETARY KAREN ROSS ON
THE AG SIDE ALONG WITH SECRETARY
TOM VILSACK AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
TO BRING THESE PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTIES TOGETHER. AS THE CHAIR
SAID WE'RE SIMPLY A LANDLORD
PORT BUT WE HAVE AN OUTSIZED
RESPONSIBILITY TO BRING THESE
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTIES TOGETHER
AND BRING MORE COMMERCE NOT ONLY
TO THE STATE BUT TO THE
INTERNATIONAL LANDSCAPE. AND MY
LAST IS THAT I SAW ONE OF YOUR
BULLET POINTS WAS BETTER USE OF
EXISTING CAPACITY. IT'S
FRUSTRATING TO HEAR THAT YOU'RE
BETTER USE OF IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN DOING TOP NOTCH ALL ALONG
TO MAKE SURE WE GOT OUR IMPORTS
AND EXPORTS UP. SO AGAIN IS THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING I'M GONNA KEEP
MY EYE ON BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING IT ALL
ALONG WE SHOULD HAVE SOME KIND
OF VISION AND FORESIGHT- SO
AGAIN APPRECIATE PRESENTATION
TODAY. AND I'LL BE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH IN THE
FUTURE. AND YOU SHOULD KEEP YOUR
EYE ON THIS AGAIN. 55% OF TRUCK
GATES GO UNUSED EVERY DAY. 30%
OF REAL CAPACITY. IS OUT THERE
WAITING FOR INTERMODAL CARGO TO
TRANSIT THROUGH OUR PORT
FACILITY. IN THIS PRIVATE
SECTOR. AREA OF OUR BUSINESS
WE'VE GOT THE CAPACITY TO MOVE
MORE CARGO CREATE MORE JOB MORE
TAX DOLLARS. AND MORE
INVESTMENTS INTO OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN. THE PRIVATE SECTOR NEEDS
TO JOIN YOU. AND ME IN THIS
EFFORT THANK YOU. BY ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MISTER STRONG
SUPPORTER LOS ANGELES MR FONG.
WITH. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
JUST A FEW QUESTIONS AND A LIST
OF ALL OUT THERE AND CAN- LIKE
ANSWERED THEM- AS YOU SEE FIT
BUT FIRST I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
JUST GIVE US A BROAD OVERVIEW
HOW MANY SHIPS RIGHT NOW ARE OFF
THE OFF THE COAST- WHAT'S THE
AVERAGE TO ALL TIME- AS THE
TREND GOING DOWN AS YOU GUYS ARE
GOING UP AND DOWN LOOKING AT THE
DATA IT LOOKS LIKE. WE'VE KIND
OF. WE JUST KIND OF WHAT KIND OF
STAGNATED A LITTLE BIT AND ONE
OF YOU CAN. GVE US A QUICK
UPDATE ON THAT. ALSO WANTED TO
KNOW- HOW HAS THE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR OPERATION THE PORTS AND
WORKING OUT. OF YOUR PARTNERS IN
OTHER PORTS BEEN FOLLOWING SUIT.
AS WELL AS WHAT'S BEEN OCCURRING
DOWN THE SUPPLY CHAIN WITH THE
WAREHOUSES AND THE DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS. AND THEN LASTLY- YOU
MENTIONED- AND YOU ONE OF YOUR
SLIDES AS SUPPLY CHAIN. SUPPLY
CHANGES DIGITAL DIGITALIZATION-
IN TERMS OF. COULD YOU GO INTO
SOME SPECIFICS IN TERMS OF WHAT
TYPES OF INVESTMENTS NEED TO BE
DONE MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
EVERY PORT HAS A- A TECHNOLOGY A
DATABASE- ITS OWN- PROPRIETARY-
YOU KNOW- IT YOU KNOW I. T.
SYSTEM. WHAT IS BEING DONE TO
KIND OF. BRING MOTHER GATHER
HAVE THEM TALK TO EACH OTHER-
WHAT CAN BE DONE IN THAT SPACE.
THANK YOU MR FONG I'LL GO IN
REVERSE ORDER ON ON THE QUESTION
OF DIGITIZATION WE'RE THIRTY
YEARS BEHIND OTHER OTHER TRADING
NATIONS IN THE SYRIAN EL ALL
IT'S ABOUT IS INFORMATION
SHARING. WE HAVE THAT IN OUR
NATIONAL ELECTRICAL ENERGY GRID
WE HAVE IT IN AIR
TRANSPORTATION. AND ALL OTHER
PARTS OF OUR PUBLIC SECTOR WE
DON'T HAVE IT. IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN IN FACT WE CAN TRACK OF
PIZZA. COMING FOR MORE ORDER TO
OUR HOME BETTER THAN WE CAN
TRACK A CONTAINER. WHETHER IT'S
KALISTA IN SINGAPORE NEXT PORT
IN BELGIUM OR DE COZY IN GERMANY
WERE WELL BEHIND OTHER TRADING
NATIONS AND MY AT BECAUSE HE HAS
BEEN VERY SIMPLE LET'S TAKE THIS
DATA SO WE CAN SEE AROUND
CORNERS PLAN OUR STAFFING AND
EQUIPMENT. TO UNDERSTAND HOW
QUICKLY CARGO WAS COMING IN AND
WHERE WE CAN DISTRIBUTE IT WHAT
WE SEEN SO FAR FOR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND SOME OF OUR PUBLIC
SECTOR COUNTERPARTS. IS THE FEAR
THAT IT WILL IMPROVE LESSER
SERVING PROVIDERS AND WE'VE GOT
TO GET PAST THAT WE'RE ONLY
ASKING FOR GENERIC INFORMATION
ORIGIN DESTINATION WHERE YOUR
CARGO WAS GONNA GO NEXT ON RAIL
OR TRUCK. NO ONE IS GONNA STRIP
A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE FROM OUR
PRIVATE OR PUBLIC SECTOR
PARTNERS WE'VE GOT A KNOCK THAT
OUT AND MOVE FORWARD LIKE THE
REST OF THE WORLD HAS DONE. ON
THE OTHER TRANSPORT CENTERS I
WILL REPORT TO YOU ACCORDING TO
THE AMERICAN TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION WE'RE SHORT EIGHTY
THOUSAND TRUCK DRIVERS
NATIONWIDE AND HERE THE HARBOR
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE MAY BE SHORT THREE FOUR EVEN
FIVE THOUSAND TRUCK DRIVERS.
THESE BOOKS ARE ASKED TO WORK NO
MORE THAN ELEVEN HOURS A DAY OR
IF THEY WERE CONSECUTIVELY TO
TAKE TIME OFF EVEN THE NOTION OF
WORKING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN CAN'T
BE ACCOMPLISHED. IN LESS WE HAVE
ENOUGH TALENT WE'VE GOT TO
RECRUIT ATTRACTIVE RETAIN BETTER
FOLKS RECREATE THIS PROFESSION.
MY GRANDFATHER WAS A TEAMSTER
DRIVING FOR THE AMERICAN CAN
COMPANY IN NEW YORK CITY FOR
FORTY YEARS. HE PLEDGE THROUGH
SCHOOL HE REYES GRANDCHILDREN
THROUGH A PROFESSION WE GOT TO
BRING THAT BACK HOME HERE TO
CALIFORNIA WHERE HOUSING WE
BOAST TWO BILLION SQUARE FEET
FROM THE SHORES OF THE PACIFIC.
OUT TO THE DESERT REGION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA INTEREST
KNOW WHETHER WHERE HOUSING
COMPLEX IN THE WORLD HAS THIS
CAPACITY YET NATIONWIDE WERE
SHORT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
WORKERS HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WERE SHORT AND
THOUSAND NOW WE SEE SIGNS UP
HELP WANTED. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR WITHOUT BENEFITS. WE NEED
TO RECREATE THAT PROFESSION WHEN
I STARTED IN THIS INDUSTRY. YOU
CAN BEGIN THIS UP BOX PERSON
RISE UP TO A SUPERVISOR ONE DAY
MANAGE THAT ENTIRE WAREHOUSE WE
GOTTA GET THE PROFESSION ACT IN
OUR WAREHOUSE A COMPLEX AS WE
BUY MORE AT THE RETAIL LEVEL AN
ONLINE. WE PICK UP AT OUR
CURBSIDE WE'VE GOT CARGO COMING
IN THAT IS CO MINGLED WITH
TRADITION CENTERS CROSS STOCKS
AND FOR BILL MENSAH'S FACILITIES
WE NEED TO WERE WRECKED MORE
FACILITIES SEQUEL HAS BEEN AN
INHIBITOR TO THAT. WHILE WE
DON'T WANT TO GO AGAINST THE
THIRD RAIL WE HAVE GOT TO
SUPPORT THE NATION'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. AND THE CARGO THAT
MOVES THROUGH THIS PORT REACHES
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF OUR
NATION'S FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS TO
BE ON CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT
ONE IN FIFTY TWO JOBS
NATIONWIDE. AND YOUR FIRST
QUESTION ABOUT HOW MANY SHIPS
ARE ON THE WAY HOW MANY TO
RANCOR I WOULD ADVISE YOU SIR
POLITELY. NOT TO MESS SHIPS THE
CARGO SHIPS THAT ARE ON THEIR
WAY LEAVING ASIA AND READY TO
ENTER THE SPORT COMPLEX
REPRESENT ABOUT TWO WEEKS. OF
WORK HERE AT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES IF WE HAD MORE TRUCKERS
IF WE HAD MORE WAREHOUSE WORKERS
AND THE ABILITY TO ABSORB THIS
CARGO IN PLACES LIKE JOLIET
ILLINOIS WEST MEMPHIS ARKANSAS
ARKANSAS. AND ALLIANCE OUTSIDE
OF FORT WORTH WE COULD BRING
MORE CARGO THROUGH THIS PORT
COMPLEX THE CARD. IS ON HIS WAY
RIGHT NOW REPOR SINCE AN EARLY
LUNAR NEW YEAR WHICH JUST STORE
YES. IN ASIA WE'LL SEE THOSE
LANDINGS COMING IN THIRD FOURTH
WEEK OF FEBRUARY AND THEN AS
MAJOR RETAILERS AND HOME
IMPROVEMENT STORES TELL ME THE
SECOND QUARTER OF THIS YEAR WILL
BE A BOON TO THE FREIGHT
INDUSTRY. BECAUSE WE'LL BE
SEEING MORE REPLENISHMENT
INVENTORY COMING THROUGH THE
INVENTORY SALES RATIO NATIONWIDE
RIGHT NOW IS THE LOWEST IT'S
BEEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
IF WE GET THROUGH THESE TWO
SEGMENTS WELL AND I BELIEVE WE
WILL AS THE UPPLY CHAIN
INDUSTRY DRIVEN BY THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WILL MOVE TO AN EARLY
PEAK SEASON IN LATE JUNE EARLY
JULY. AND START BRINGING IN
THOSE SEATS PRODUCTS AS WELL AS
HOLIDAY GOODS THROUGH THE
NATION'S LARGEST GATEWAY. THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU I JUST WHAT IF
I GUESS ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
IN TERMS OF I THINK YOUR FIRST
YEAR NO ANSWER TO MY FIRST
COURT- FIRST QUESTION. AND THEY
HAVE MY AT YOUR ANSWER TO THAT
THEIR QUESTION GO TOGETHER IN
TERMS OF INFORMATION SHARING I
THINK THAT IS AN EMPHASIS THAT
WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON- KIND
OF IN THE SAME VEIN AS MY- MY
COLLEAGUE FOR WINTERS. IS THAT
WE HAVE TO KNOW WHERE EVERYTHING
IS AND IN REAL TIME AS CHAIR
MENTION. YOU KNOW OF OUR AG GUYS
CAN'T FIND CONTAINERS IT MIGHT.
BE NECESSARY TO KNOW AND TRACK
WHERE THOSE CONTAINERS ARE IN SO
YOU FOR THIRTY YEARS BEHIND TO
WORK AT THE CATCH UP VERY VERY
QUICKLY. AND IF THE METRICS
YOU'RE SAYING IS. DON'T LOOK AT
THE SHIPS OF THE SEA OF THE
CONTAINERS OFF THE COAST WELL
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO LOOK AT.
APPLE WE NEED. DATA TO- TO
UNDERSTAND. THE OF THE PROBLEM I
UNDERSTAND I CERTAINLY. AND
SYMPATHETIC TO THE FACT THAT WE
GOT CHOKEPOINTS EVERYWHERE. BUT
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE MAY BE
INVESTING MORE MONEY IN THE I.
T. SPACE. AND INFORMATION
SHARING SPACE AND I WOULD JUST
ASK. NOW THAT YOU'VE GIVEN US A
THREE THOUSAND FOOT VIEW HOW DO
WE EXECUTED. IF WE'RE THIRTY
YEARS BEHIND. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS ARE ALL
SPOT ON. AND WHILE I SAY DON'T
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF SHIPS
COMING IN THAT'S IMPORTANT BUT
IT'S A LAND USE SYMBOL LAS CITY
ISSUE. NUMBER OF DAYS THAT
CONTAINERS SIT IMPACT THE
ABILITY TO MOVE CARGO THROUGH
OUR PORTS RAIL AND TRUCK
ACTIVITIES CARGILL IS SITTING
LONGER THAN EVER AND WHILE BACK
IN OCTOBER. WE ANNOUNCED A
PENALTY FEE ON CARGO THAT WAS
SITTING NINE DAYS OR LONGER TO
THIS MALL WE'VE NEVER COLLECTED
A DIME BUT WE REDUCE THOSE AGING
CONTAINERS. BY 71% AS OF THIS
MORNING AND THE REASON WE DID
THAT WAS BECAUSE WE HAD ACCESS
TO THIS DATA AND UNDERSTOOD HAD
A SEGMENT CARGO THERE WAS NO
PUBLIC SHAMING OF THOSE
RETAILERS WHO BROUGHT IN TV'S
AHEAD OF SUPER BOWL LAST JUNE.
LOUNGE CHAIRS PATIO FURNITURE
THAT DIDN'T NEED TO GET TO
MARKET IN COMPETITION WITH
HOLIDAY GOODS PRODUCTS FOR
MACHINES FOR HOSPITALS AND THOSE
FACTORY PARTS THAT NEEDED TO GET
TO THE MANUFACTURER'S FLOORS WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD AND PUSH
ASIDE. THE OBSTRUCTIONISTS WHO
DON'T WANT TO SHARE DATA AT ITS
GENERIC IN ITS OWN RIGHT AND IT
ALLOWS US TO PREPARE OUR
STAFFING AND EQUIPMENT TO MOVE
EVEN MORE CARGO AND WHAT I WOULD
RECOMMEND YOU LOOK AT. IS THE
DWELL TIME HOW LONG CONTAINER
SET WHETHER THEY BE ON SHIPS. ON
DOCK WAITING FOR RAIL OR WAITING
FOR TRUCK IF THE VELOCITY THOSE
CONTAINERS START TO MOVE MORE
QUICKLY YOUR THROUGHPUT CAPACITY
AT THE STATE'S ELEVEN PORTS.
ALSO INCREASES WE POST ALL THESE
AND MANY OTHER MEASURES ON THE
HERO SLIDE OF OUR PORT WEBSITE
EVERY DAY AND THROUGH VARIOUS
SOCIAL MEDIA CHANNELS AS WELL AS
LINKED IN ON A DAILY BASIS I'M
HAPPY TO TALK TO MORE OFF LINE.
ABOUT WHAT WE MEASURE IN THE
LOGISTICIANS LOOK AT TO IMPROVE
THE SUPPLY CHAIN BUT YOU'RE.
SPOT ON WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
RIGHT NOW. BUT JUST ONE
HIGHLIGHT DWELL TIME HE ACTUALLY
OF ISSUE. GARNERED A LOT OF IN
THE PRESS. BUT IT'S NEVER BEEN
IMPLEMENTED RIGHT BUT IT'S BEEN
A CITY IT APPEARS AS A BETTER
SIGNIFICANT MOTIVATOR TO CLEAN
SOME OF THE CONTAINERS OFF. THE
DOCKS IS THAT ACCURATE. IT
DOESN'T APPEAR IT WORKED THERE
IS 71% OF THOSE AGING CONTAINERS
THAT MOVED OFF DOCK WE-
RETAILERS WHO IMPORT PRODUCTS
THAT HAD UNBELIEVABLY RICH
AGREEMENTS TO USE THE PORT. AS A
STORAGE FACILITY WE SMOKE THEM
OUT WE DIDN'T PUBLICLY SHAME
THEM BUT WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THESE OTHER PRODUCTS TO MARKET
BY SEGMENTING THAT CARGO WAS
SIDE AND I THINK IS NOW IN THE
MIDDLE OF CONTRACTING SEASON
BETWEEN THE OCEAN LINER
COMPANIES AND THOSE IMPORTERS OF
RECORD WE'LL SEE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT DISCIPLINE AND HOW WE
MANAGE CARGO THAT FLOWS THROUGH
THE SPORTS. GREAT OUTDOOR
MAJORITY LEADER. DISTRESS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER STRUCK I
REPRESENTED THE INLAND EMPIRE
THE HEART OF THE LOGISTICS
INDUSTRY. AND IN THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM OCTOBER HE
DID DIRECT THE STATE AGENCIES TO
IDENTIFY PRIORITY FREIGHT ROUTES
TO BE CONSIDERED TO ALLOW TRUCKS
TO CARRY MORE GOODS. MIKE MY
QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF THE PORT
OF LA WHAT ROUTES HAVE YOU ALL
IDENTIFIED AS PRIORITY FREIGHT
ROUTES AND WHAT CRITERIA DID YOU
USE TO DETERMINE THOSE. THE
CARGO THAT THOUGHT COMES THROUGH
OUR PORT HERE IN LOS ANGELES IS
SEGMENTED IN THREE WAYS NUMBER
ONE THAT WHICH MOVES BY A TRUCK
THAT GOES TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES HERE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY POPULATION IS YOU KNOW.
OF ABOUT TEN MILLION PEOPLE. THE
NEXT SEGMENT IS THE CARGO THAT
MOVES OUT TO YOUR AREA IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE THAT GOES THROUGH
A SERIES OF WAREHOUSES
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS AND
FULFILLMENT LOCATIONS THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER. THE BALANCE
THIRD IS THE INTACT
INTERNATIONAL OCEAN BOX THAT
GETS LOADED ON DOCK WITH RAIL
THEY MOVES OUT TO CHICAGO
MEMPHIS DALLAS ATLANTA AND OTHER
LOCATIONS ALL OF THESE CORRIDORS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US. WHAT I'VE
RECOMMENDED TO THE INDUSTRY AND
IN MY BOTH SHORT AND LONG TERM
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THE FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS IS THAT
WE SEGMENT THAT CARGO. AND HOW
BETTER WE CAN APPORTION IT
LOADING TO THE SHIPS IN ASIA
WILL ALLOW FOR GREATER
EFFICIENCIES HERE ONCE IT
REACHES THE SHORES AT THE PORT
OF LOS ANGELES. THINK ABOUT IT
THIS WAY IF WE CAN UNLOAD CARGO
THAT'S MOVING TO THE RP
OVERNIGHT. WAYS AND ROAD RACING
AWAY FROM COMMUTERS AND SCHOOL
BUSES WE GET THE PRODUCTS OUT TO
YOUR LOCATIONS QUICKER AND TO
THOSE DISTRIBUTION FACILITIES
WERE OFFERING UPPER GATES HERE
SO TRUCKERS WHO ARE TYPICALLY
PAID BY THE RUN. DON'T HAVE TO
SIT IN LINE FOR HOURS ON TIME.
ALSO BY CREATING INLAND
CONTAINER DEPOTS WHETHER THEY BE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR IN THE
I. E. WILL ALLOW US TO
ACCELERATE NEW AND BETTER
CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES THANK WILL
HELP IN SPOKE CONCEPT. RUNNING
THE CARGO OUT TO LOCATIONS IN
THE ID AND THE DISTRIBUTING THAT
WAS ZERO EMISSIONS TECHNOLOGY ON
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS TO WAREHOUSE
LOCATIONS CLOSER BY CAN ALLOW
THE ACCELERATION OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. LAUT TRUCK DRIVERS TO
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHEN
THEY CAN WORK THEY COULD BE HOME
FOR DINNER AT NIGHT THEY CAN
WORK OVERNIGHT IF THAT'S WHAT
THEY WISH TO DO. AND IT'S A
BETTER PLAN SUPPLY CHAIN LIKE
MANY OTHER TRADING NATIONS HAVE
THAT WE CAN USE TO BRING THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. TO A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE. SO SPECIFICALLY ON
THE PRIORITY FREIGHT ROUTES
THOUGH. AND FOR THE INLAND
EMPIRE HAVE THOSE BEEN
IDENTIFIED ALREADY. WHERE ARE WE
ON THE IN THAT PROCESS IN
RESPONSE TO. ORDER I WOULD YOU
TO FIND A PRIORITY FREIGHT ROUTE
MA'AM. THAT'S THE QUESTION IS
THAT. THE EXECUTIVE ORDER-
CHARGED. CHARGED YOU WITH
PUTTING TOGETHER THE PRIORITY
FREIGHT ROUTES AND I THINK IF
THERE'S A QUESTION TO THE
QUESTION IS TO THE GOVERNOR. IF
HE HAS IF THIS ISN'T HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER THEN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HE IS ASKING BE
DONE. IT'S AN EXIT BOTH THE
AREAS OF RESPONSIBILITY RESIGN
RESIDE WITH CALLOUS TO AND DOES
OF FEDERAL DOT WERE. ALWAYS
WORKING WITH BOTH AGENCIES AND
AGAIN I'LL LET THE DATA TAKE ME
WHERE YOUR QUESTION LIES
PRIORITY FROM BROWN'S. INLAND
EMPIRE ONE THIRD OF THE OF THE
CARGO THAT MOST YEAR CARLA MOVES
THROUGH LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS
THE SECOND THIRD THE INTACT
OCEAN BOX MOVING TO THE INTERIOR
OF THE COUNTRY IS THE THIRD.
THAT PRIORITY FREE ROUTE AS
DESIGNATED NETTY IO WILL LEND US
TO NOT ONLY PUBLIC SECTOR
DESIGNATION AND BUDGETS BUT-
PRIVATE SECTOR MONEY TO FOLLOW
SO HAPPY TO TALK TO YOU MORE
ABOUT THIS OFF LINE IT'S A
LITTLE NUANCED. BUT I THINK
WHERE YOU'RE GOING IS ABSOLUTELY
APPROPRIATE TO HELP SUPPORT YOUR
AREA. THANK YOU. MISTER VEHICLE
. THANK THEY WERE IRATE ON FROM
NIGHT I. THE PROBLEM. AND I'M
GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP ABOUT
TRUCKING RIGHT- AND THAT'S GONNA
BE A PROBLEM THAT WE ALL NEED TO
GET INVOLVED BECAUSE- THIRTY
PERCENT. HAVE RETIRED AND IT'S
GONNA BE EVEN A BIGGER ISSUE
THAT WE NEED TO DIVE INTO. THE
THAT I'M VERY THANKFUL FOR YOU
BRING THAT UP THE QUESTION THAT
I HAVE FOR YOU IS THAT I KEEP
HEARING IS THAT. IT'S A SECURITY
ISSUE FOR DRIVERS TO GET THROUGH
THE PORT. CAN YOU ELABORATE ON
THAT. IS THAT SLOWING THIS DOWN
WHEN THEY GET TO THE PORT. I
HAVE BEEN AT THIS PORT FOR EIGHT
YEARS I AM UNAWARE OF ANY
SECURITY ISSUE THAT IMPEDES
TRUCKERS THE SAFETY AND SECURITY
OF ALL PORT WORKERS
ADMINISTRATIVE OR OPERATIONAL IS
FRONT OF MIND EVERY DAY ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE SEEN FOR
A LONG TIME EVEN PRE DATING MY
TIME HERE. IS HOW LONG IT TAKES
THE TRUCKER TO ENTER. THE HARBOR
DISTRICT AREA KITTY INSIDE THE
MARINE TERMINAL PRIVATE SECTOR
OPERATED. DROP OFF THEIR INTO
YOUR EXPORT KICK UP THEIR LOADED
CONTAINER A MOVE IT BACK TO THE
CUSTOMER THAT WE MUTUALLY SHARE.
OF SECURITY IS NOT AN ISSUE HERE
AT THE NATION'S LARGEST PORT BUT
WHAT'S BEEN IN THE NEWS LARGE.
OVER RECENT WEEKS AND MONTHS OR
THE FUNDS TIMELY AND
INCOMPREHENSIBLE. FIFTHS OF RAIL
CARS OUTSIDE OF LOS ANGELES
PROPER IN THE EASTERN PART OF
THE REGION WITH THIEVES
RUMMAGING THROUGH RAIL
CONTAINERS LOOKING FOR PARCELS
AND PACKAGES AND OTHER GOODS TO
DISTRIBUTE FOR THEIR OWN USE
WORKING WITH THE ALLIED AGENCIES
AND LED BY PORT POLICE CHIEF AND
HEAD OF PUBLIC SAFETY TOM CASEY.
WE HAVE AN EYE ON EXACTLY WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IN THIS AREA
THE HELP THE PRIVATE SECTOR
BURLINGTON NORTHERN SANTA FE
RAILROAD UNION PACIFIC RAILROAD
WHO JUST BECAUSE IT IT US
YESTERDAY. OUR POLL WORKING
TOGETHER AND SAFETY AND SECURITY
FOR THE TRUCKER INJURING THIS
PORT IS ALWAYS A TOP PRIORITY
FOR US AND NOT AN IMPEDIMENT. TO
THOSE DRIVERS THAT COME HERE.
WELL I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE I READ
REPRESENT THE PORT OF STOCKTON.
AND I JUST WANTED TO ASSURE
EVERYONE HERE IN THIS ROOM THAT
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER THIS IS NOT A ABOUT A
COMPETITION OF CALIFORNIA IF
WE'RE COMPETING THE WITH ANYONE
IT MIGHT BE SOMEONE FROM AT
BAKKIES BUT- THE PORT OF
STOCKTON. ARE HERE TO HELP WE'RE
WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE I
ALWAYS HERE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT-
MYSTERY TO ALWAYS TALK ABOUT TAG
WHICH IS VERY DEAR TO OUR HEART.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ENSURE THAT WE ARE WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE HELPING WERE
SUPPLEMENTING. THE IN PART OF
THE PORT ISSUES SO TRACKING IS
ONE THAT IS GOING TO BE.
SOMETHING THAT I'M GLAD YOU
BROUGHT UP BECAUSE- TRUCK A
TRUCK DRIVER GET A THEIR CLASS
LICENSE THIRTY DAYS OKAY SB
BEHIND A RIG. AND WORKING- AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PUTTING SOME. SOME VOCATIONAL
TRAINING IN THAT HELLO THIS IS
THIS CAN THIS COULD BE. A QUICK
FIX. BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE WERE SUPPORTING FOLKS
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU. SB A VOTER I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WE TALK
ABOUT SECURITY MIGHT BE THE NEED
FOR A TWIX CARD TO GET ON THE
PORT PROPERTY. THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO JUST LET ANYONE WALK ON PORT
PROPERTY BECAUSE A HOMELAND
SECURITY ISSUES I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK FOR THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF YOU WANT TO QUICKLY COMMENT
ON THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MISTER
CHAIR YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT THE
TRANSPORTATION WORKER
IDENTIFICATION CARD OF WHICH I
HOLD ALONG WITH EVERYONE ELSE
THAT COMES INTO THESE ELEVEN
PORTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ARE
ABSOLUTELY A NECESSITY. AND FOR
FOLKS TO OPEN UP THIS AREA MAKE
SURE THEY QUALIFY. DRUG TESTING
CREDENTIALS WORKING FOR A
COMPANY. CAPITALIZED CENTER ARE
ALL FRONT AND CENTER AND IT'S
LED BY THE FEDERAL INITIATIVES.
TO THE STATE LEVEL HERE TO
MUNICIPALITIES IF THERE ARE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO WORK ON
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
FAIRNESS ACROSS THE BOARD. OF
COURSE I AM AVAILABLE TO YOU AT
ALL TIMES. GREAT THANK YOU
ADJUST QUICKLY- COULD YOU GO
OVER THE CALIFORNIA CONNECT.
EFFORT YOU HAVE. YEAH THE IDEA
IS PRETTY SIMPLE AND ALTHOUGH
OUR INDUSTRY IS SO NUANCED AND
COMPLEX AND IN ALL THE YEARS
I'VE WORKED UP STILL LEARNING
SOMETHING EVERY DAY BUT THE
IDEAS IS SIMPLE BRING THE SHORT
THE PACIFIC CLOSER TO WHERE THE
CARGO IS WHETHER IT BE IN THE
COUNTY OF MERCED UP TO STOCKTON
AND FRESNO OUT TO THE INLAND
EMPIRE TO RANCHO CUCAMONGA
ONTARIO IT'S CETERA LET'S MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BRING CARGO IN THE CARGO OWNERS
CLOSER TO THE PORT. TO THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S QUESTION
EARLIER THESE KEY CORRIDORS THAT
WE'VE CALLED IN VARIOUS PEOPLE
HAVE DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS BUT
IT'S ABOUT BRINGING CARGO OUT
THERE SWIFTER AND QUICKER AND IF
WE HAVE THE ABILITY FIRE RAIL OR
TRUCK TO HAVE EASY ACCESS CREATE
GREEN GATES OF OUR TERMINALS AND
MAKE SURE YOU CAN GET CARGO ON
RAIL FOR MERCED DOWN TO THE PORT
OF LOS ANGELES INTO AN
INDIVIDUAL TERMINAL IT MAKES THE
SPEED AND EFFICIENCY OF THE
SPORT. EVEN MORE IMPORTANT A
THIRD OF THE CARGO ON THE IMPORT
SIDE GOES OUT TO THE I. E. WE'D
LIKE RECIPROCAL CARGO COMING
BACK AND AGAIN IF WE COULD MOVE
IT DURING OFF PEAK HOURS FREE UP
THE GATES FOR THOSE MERCHANTS
AND STORE OWNERS THAT NEED CARGO
IN IT JUST IN TIME BASIS WITH
THOSE WHO NEED IT JUST IN CASE
THAT MAKES OUR BUSINESS
PROPOSITION EVEN MORE. IMPORTANT
TO THE INTERNATIONAL TRADER
COUNTRY AND PARTNER THAT WE WANT. TO BRING IT TO THIS COMPLEX.
GREAT THANK YOU- AYE MR SIRI. I
DO AND I JUST WHAT DO YOU KNOW.
A THE STATE'S ROLE- YOU TALK
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE THERE'S THE
IT INFRASTRUCTURE. AND ANOTHER
IS A BUDGET ASKING FOR THAT FROM
THE PORTS BOTH PORTS. AND ALSO
SOME MONEY FOR OFFICERS AND HARD
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND YOU CITED
SEEK WAS BEING A CHALLENGE IT
LOOKS SEEK WAS QUITE FRANKLY PUT
US IN A STALEMATE. WE CAN'T DO
IT LESS ZERO BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ZERO WE CAN'T DO IT. SO THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS MAYBE WE GO
NEAR ZERO AND THEN WHEN THE TIME
COMES GO TO ZERO WHEN THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS AVAILABLE. SO THAT
SOMETHING POLICY MAKERS HAVE TO
CONSIDER BECAUSE SPORTS HAVE TO
MAKE GREEN TO GO GREEN. AND WE
NEED MORE VELOCITY WE NEED MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME- VERNON LOOKS TO HAVE
TO LOOK CLOSELY AT HOW WE CAN
USE SEQUENCE TO ACHIEVE
CERTAINLY ARE GREEN GOALS BUT
ALSO OUR GOALS OF MOVING. GOODS
THROUGH THE PORTS MORE
EFFICIENTLY WITH THAT I THINK
YOU MISTER SOROKA. AS DOES THE
REST OF THE PANEL WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT- MISTER
STROKE IS NOT GOING TO LEAVE. SO
THANK AGAIN. I WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE REST OF OUR
PANEL AND- I'M GOING TO
INTRODUCE. A MIKE JACOB HE'S
VICE PRESIDENT AND GENERAL
COUNSEL AT PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION. OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS PMSA- MISTER- JACOB YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE- READY
WHEN YOU APPEAR. AND YOU COULD
ALSO MAYBE EXPLAIN THE ROLE OF
PIANO SAY AS WELL. WHAT YOUR
ORGANIZATION DOES BURKE. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING- GEN AND-
GENERATED SOME MEMBERS REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPTION TO BE HERE
TODAY AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES AND FOCUSING ON HOW TO
IMPROVE CALPERS BACK AT WORK
ECONOMY GIVEN WHERE WE ARE- THAT
CAME AS A HAVE YOU NOTED WE
REPRESENT BLAME TERMINAL
OPERATORS AND OCEAN CARRIERS-
HAND WRITTEN BY TO TODAY TO
FOLLOW UP ON. MISTER SIROCCO
STREAMLINING PRESENTATION TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT HE PRESENTED NOW
THAT ACTUALLY MOVES INTO THE
OPERATIONAL ENVIRONMENT WHY IS
IT IMPORTANT THAT THE LOCAL I.
PANDEMIC INTO SUPPLY CHAIN
SYMPTOMS THAT THAT EXACTLY
DIRECTOR SIR OKAY JUST OUTLINED-
AND HOW DO THEY MANIFEST
THEMSELVES IN THE PORT. WHAT
SHOULD THE REASON WHY WE'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT IMPORTS IN
ORDER TALK ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE
EXPORTS AND I THINK WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM HIM IN YOUR JACKLEY
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ONE
FOCUS ON THE NEWS VERY VERY
BRIEF CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
CAN MOVE LONG DWELLING IMPORTANT
VIEWS OFF OF OUR CONGESTED
TERMINALS FIRST AND FOCUS ON MAC
IN ORDER TO GET BACK TO
SOMETHING THAT. LOOKS LIKE OUR
PRE COATED EQUILIBRIUM OUT OF
PLACE BRING UP CHASSIS IS IN
ORDER TO MAKE MORE WOMEN
AVAILABLE BOTH FOR IMPORTERS AND
EXPORTERS THROUGHOUT OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN THAT'S REALLY OUR FOCUS
RIGHT NOW- WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE PORTS
FINISH- DAMAGING MENTIONED ON
THE SIX AT THE MOVING ALONG WELL
AND GIVES OFF THAT WAS REALLY A
RESULT OF WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR PORT PARTNERS. HAPPY MORNING
TERMINAL OPERATORS AT THE TABLE
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE ON A MEMBER
STATE LEADERS AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE KEEP
A GOOD MOVING THROUGH THE SYSTEM
CONTINUE- AND WE EXPAND ON THEM
WINNING BEST IN THE MOVING
FORWARD- TO THE OPERATIONAL
QUESTION VERY DIRECTLY- OUR
SYSTEM WIDE CONGESTION DURING
THE. JIM WAS TALKING ABOUT
MANIFESTED SO IN A TERM. SO AN
ARMORY TERMINAL OPERATOR- WE
HAVE SO MUCH ACREAGE SOME
ABILITY TO MOVE CARGO. WHEN THAT
TERMINAL IS FOR. OF CAR. IN
LATER. EXPORT WORK. IT'S OUR
VESSEL LOW AND I TO. THAT EXTRA
OUR TIME IN BIRTH- AND WHEN WE
EXTEND TIME OF BIRTH WE HAVE
LATEST. THE DEAD LATEST PHYSICS
WE'VE SEEN WITH THAT THROUGH Q.
FOUR OF TWO THOUSAND TWO ONE
AVERAGE TIME FOR BOTH OF THE
BIRTH IN NORTH. WAS SEVEN DAYS
THAT'S 20% LONGER THAN WAS
PRETTY PENDEK IN THE CASCADES WE
SHIP STATE OF BIRTH LONGER
THERE'S BEEN FURTHER OFF
SCHEDULE. AND WHEN THEY'RE OFF
SCHEDULE THE BACK OF THE SHIP
BEHIND THEM PUTTING THEM FURTHER
OFF SCHEDULE WHEN SHIPS ARE
COLLECTIVELY DELAYED NOT
SCHEDULING NORTH AMERICA. THAT'S
THE WAY THINKING JOBS THE RETURN
TO ASIA WE END UP WITH SKIP
SAILINGS MISS SAILINGS AN
ADDITIONAL DELAY ALL OF THESE
THINGS. BASICALLY. RESULT IN
LESS CAPACITY. EIGHT TIMES HI
RATES MARKOFF'S. PROFICIENCY WHY
WE'RE DEALING WITH HIGH VOLUME-
YOU KNOW. AGAIN WE CAN'T
REEMPHASIZED ENOUGH AND IT
PROBABLY GOES WITHOUT SAYING-
BUT I WANT TO REITERATE HERE. WE
ARE MOVING MORE CARGO THAN EVER
BEFORE. IN THE MIDST OF PANDEMIC
IT IS WORTH AGAIN TAKING THE
TIME OUT TO SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
DEDICATED WATERFRONT LABOR
FORCE. ALL OF OUR SUPPLY CHAIN
PARTNERS. MOVING AS A CENTRAL
WORKERS IN THIS ECONOMY HAS BEEN
TOUGH PEOPLE ARE DOING IT- BUT-
TO THE POINT OF THIS THIS
HEARING- WE HAVEN'T DONE A
PERFECT- IT HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN
PRETTY AND THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT
OF MISSTEPS AND THOSE COSTS ARE
THEN REFLECTED IN THE SYSTEM. WE
HAVE TO WORK OUR WAY OUT OF
BALANCE BY FOCUSING ON WHAT WE
CAN CONTROL AND THAT'S TRYING TO
REDUCE TERMINAL CONGESTION. THE
OTHER CONTEXTS BROTHER THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY THAT- THE ACTUAL WAY
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT THE PORT
ECOSYSTEM IS STILL IN THE
CONTEXT OF PRE COATED AND IT
SHOULD BE. BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE
IS THE ENVIRONMENT WHICH HAS
ALWAYS BEEN ESSENTIALLY FRAMED
BY THE CONTEXT WITHIN THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY. WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
TRADE DEFICIT. THE UNITED STATES
ISN'T IMPORTING NATION- AND WHAT
THAT HAS MEANT IS THAT WE ALWAYS
HAVE AN IMBALANCE IN TOTAL TRADE
BUT WE FOUND AN EQUILIBRIUM FOR
EVERY CAN CAN ONLY BRING AND
EVENTUALLY THAT NEEDS TO GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE HE JUST MOVED
WHETHER IT'S FULL OR EMPTY- AND
WHAT WE FOUND IN THE NORMAL
TIMES IS THAT THAT'S A BENEFIT
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
TO OUR EXPORTERS- IN THE QUICK
EXPLANATION FOR THIS IS THE
OVERSIMPLIFICATION CARE ALL
THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING TO
BE THIS MORNING- AND I. THINK IT
BECAUSE OF THE TO THE POINT OF
SAYING. WHEN WE HAVE A ROBUST
IMPORT ECONOMY. THOSE IMPORTS OF
SAP AFFECTIVELY SUBSIDIZE OUR
ABILITY TO GROW IN CALIFORNIA
THEY UNDER RIGHT OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPROVEMENTS ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS
PRIVATELY FINANCED OUR LABOR
FORCE. AND ON A PER UNIT BASIS
THE MORE CARGO THAT WERE MOVING
ON IMPORT CAPACITY REDUCING PER
UNIT COSTS FOR EXPORTERS AND IN
A PRE CODED EQUILIBRIUM
SITUATION WE WERE ABLE TO
FACILITATE A LOT OF EXPORTS TO
ESSENTIALLY AT LEVELSWHICH WERE
NON COMPENSATORY THERE VERY
WELL. AS JEAN POINTED. OUT WE
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
BACK TO THAT. SEARCH BUT WE WANT
TO HAVE THE INCENTIVES IN PLACE
TO DO THAT THAT'S GOOD FOR
EVERYBODY- OUR LONG TERM GOAL
AND WORKING WITH OUR EXPORT
PARTNERS. IS B. RESUMPTION OF
SOMETHING THAT LOOKS LIKE A
NORMAL SIX- AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT WE ANT TO WORK VERY VERY
CLOSELY. WITH OUR EXPORT
PARTNERS ARE OCEAN CURRENTS
MAUREEN TERMINALS ARE WORKING
WITH THEM BUT THEY HAVE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES- IN MANY RESPECTS
IMPORTING A BOXES. MUCH EASIER
THAN EXPORTING. SECOND PANEL
FROM FOLKS. A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
BUT ALSO A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
WITH THE CURRENT SYSTEM. YOU
CANNOT JUST PICK UP AN EMPTY AND
EXPORTED IT'S MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT CAN YOU
DEFINE THE RIGHT TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT IF YOU CAN FIND THE
EQUIPMENT- AND WE NEED TO WORK
MUCH MORE CLOSELY WITH YOUR
KERRIER IN YOUR TERMINAL TO GET
A BOX. INCLUDING AN EXPORT SO
WITH THAT I'M I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. AGAIN WE'RE VERY
HAPPY TO BE WORKING WITH YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP- AND
EDUCATION WE'VE BEEN PREAHING
THE NEED FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE
COMPETITIVE SPOKE WITH RESPECT
TO IMPORT EXPORT CARGO. FOR
DECADES AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYONE ON THIS PANEL WORKING.
WITH US SOMETIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JACOB WILL HOLD
QUESTIONS WERE JUST A MINUTE
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO SECRETARY
ROSS MISTER. YEAH AND SO WITH US
WE HAVE- SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT FOOD
AGRICULTURE- THIS KAREN ROSS.
SECRETARY ROSS I BELIEVE IT WILL
BE WITH US- VIA. WEBEX AND FROM
HOW THE GUEST ROOM YEAH A GOOD
MORNING MR IT MINING WITH THE
CHAIR AND MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING IT IS SO
IMPORTANT AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF THE
TWO SPEAKERS BEFORE ME I REALLY
ENJOYED WORKING WITH GENE OVER
THE YEARS- AND MIGHT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS I THINK WE'VE
REALLY IDENTIFIED THE PROBLEMS
AND IT'S VERY CLEAR THERE IS NO
ONE ANSWER AND THERE IS NO ONE
STAKEHOLDER THIS REQUIRES THIS
VERY COMPLICATED MULTI
DIMENSIONAL SYSTEM THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON REQUIRES EVERYONE AS
STAKEHOLDERS. PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
TO COME TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY
SOLUTIONS AND WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO DO THAT I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY COLLEAGUES FROM
COPIOUS AND THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FOR
BENJAMIN JUST PARTNERS THEY ARE
THE CO CHAIRS OF THE GOVERNOR
SUPPLY CHAIN TASK FORCE- AND
JUST THE WORK THAT THEY DID
GOING BACK SEVEN MONTHS AGO WITH
THE FIRST ON THAT I KNOW OF A
FULL SUPPLY CHAIN OF SUPPLY
CHAIN SUCCESS SUMMIT WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL UP FOLLOW UP MEETINGS TO
THAT BECAUSE WE'RE THINKING
SHORT TERM INTERMEDIATE TERM AND
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS. BUT LET ME
PROVIDE JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS BECAUSE
AG EXPORTS ARE ONE OF THE
BRIGHTEST SPOTS IN THE TRADE
PICTURE FOR CALIFORNIA AND FOR
THE UNITED STATES TO HELP BRING
THE BALANCE OF TRADE AND. INTO
PLACE AND THAT'S WHY. IN THE
BEGINNING OF MUCH OF OUR TIME ON
THE EMPTY ISSUE AND TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SHELVES WERE
FULL OF ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
NOW MANUFACTURE OVERSEAS- AG
EXPERTS WERE GETTING AS MUCH
ATTENTION- AND MANY IN THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR WORK HARD IN
WASHINGTON DC AND HERE IN
SACRAMENTO TO RAISE THESE.
ISSUES THE STUDY THAT YOU
REFERENCE MISTER CHAIR OF OVER
TWO BILLION DOLLARS OF LOST
OPPORTUNITY AND EXPORTS ARE VERY
ACCURATE AND IF YOU HAVEN'T HAD
A CHANCE TO SEE THAT STUDY THAT
UC DAVIS WAS A PART OF. ITS
SOBERING AND IT UNDERSCORES THE
MANY ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED ABOUT MODERNIZING OUR
SYSTEM AND HAVING A REAL CLEAR
VISION. OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
GETS MOVEMENT OF INTERNATIONAL
MARKETS AND IMPROVING. ALL OF
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. I RECALL LAW EXPERTS ARE
ABOUT TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
BUT WHAT SOME MEANINGFUL ABOUT
THE ACTIVITY OF WHAT STARTS IN
OUR FIELDS ARE PASTORS AND OUR
ORCHARDS. IS THAT FOR EVERY
DOLLAR OF THAT FARMGATE VALUE.
GOING THROUGH THE CHANGE TO GO
TO AN EXPORT MARKET CREATES AN
ADDITIONAL DOLLAR AND THIRTY ONE
CENTS OF ACTIVITY. SO THERE'S A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND
JOBS THAT ARE THE RESULT OF WHAT
WE GROW HERE ADD VALUE TO HEAR.
AND SHIP THROUGH THE SYSTEM TO
REACH CONSUMERS HERE AND AROUND
THE GLOBE. THAT'S PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE ACTIVITY IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S REALLY IMPACTING
LOCAL ECONOMIES. AND THIS IS THE
PERFECT TIME TO ACKNOWLEDGE ALL
OF THE JOB CREATION. ALL OF OUR
FRIENDS AND LABOR THAT ARE
TOUCHING OUR PRODUCTS TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. IT STARTS ON THE
FARM BUT THERE ARE MANY HAS THAT
TOUCH IT ALONG THE WAY. WE
ACTUALLY EXPORT TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
BUT OUR TOP EXPORT MARKETS ARE
YOU. CANADA JAPAN. CHINA SOUTH
KOREA AND MEXICO. THIS TIME OF
YEAR WHICH IS ALREADY BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED WITH THE START OF
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR HIGH QUALITY HIGH
VALUE SPECIALTY CROPS FROM
CALIFORNIA THE LUNAR NEW YEAR IS
A PRIME SHIPPING TIME FOR US AND
FOR MANY OF OUR CROPS IT IS THE
MOST CRITICAL TIME OF THE YEAR
FOR THEIR EXPORT PRODUCTS. I'LL
TALK ABOUT MORE ABOUT ABOUT THAT
IN JUST A MOMENT- I WAS ASKED TO
GIVE SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT THE
IMPACTS HAVE BEEN TO SOME OF OUR
COMMODITIES AND I'M HAPPY TO DO
THAT. I'LL START WITH ORANGES
BECAUSE IT MIGHT MAKE A TRIP TO
CHINA AND VIETNAM AND SINGAPORE
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT A
BEAUTIFUL FRESH ORANGE THAT
MAKES IT HIGHLY DESIRABLE IT'S
HEALTHY IT'S NUTRITIOUS AT THAT
REPRESENTS A GREAT QUALITY OF
LIFE AND ARE IN HIGH DEMAND THIS
TIME OF THE YEAR FOR ALL THE
FAMILY CELEBRATIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING. AT THE CURRENT TIME
IT'S TAKING AT LEAST TEN
ADDITIONAL DAYS. FOR THAT CARGO
SHIP WITH BOTH FRESH ORANGES TO
REACH HONG KONG AND THEN BE
SHIPPED THROUGHOUT SOUTHEAST
ASIA. THOSE TEN ADDITIONAL DAYS
START TO IMPACT THE QUALITY.
THEY HAVE CAUSED SOME RELUCTANCE
BY SOME OF THE FIRES TO PLACE
THEIR ORDERS NOT KNOWING IF
THEY'RE GOING TO GET IT AND WHAT
CONDITIONS ARE GOING TO BE AN-
AND OFTENTIMES THEY'RE ASKING
FOR COMPENSATION SO. THERE'S
MANY WAYS THAT THERE'S
ADDITIONAL COSTS IN THE SYSTEM
OF GETTING OUR GUESTS TO THESE
MARKETS- AND IT'S COMING AT A
TIME WHERE WE MAY BE LOSING
CUSTOMERS SO THE FOCUS OF OUR AG
EXPORTERS. HAS BEEN VERY MUCH
FOCUSED ON TAKING EXTRAORDINARY
STEPS TO KEEP THE CUSTOMERS THAT
THEY HAVE BECAUSE IT'S SO HARD
TO BRING THEM BACK. AND THAT'S A
CASE. THEY. THINK ARE SUCH AS
SHOPPERS. JUST JUST THE
CALIFORNIA ONE FOR. AND I KNOW
THIS ONE IS NEAR AND DEAR TO
YOUR HEART ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. BUT THEY ANNOUNCED
WITH THE INVENTORY IS AT THIS
TIME OF THE YEAR THEY DO THAT ON
FEBRUARY FIRST OF EVERY YEAR.
THEY ANNOUNCED THAT THE CURRENT
INVENTORY OF IN SHELL WALNUTS IS
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVEN MILLION
POUNDS. THAT COMPARES TO RECOUNT
GAP EIGHT NORMAL LEVELS OF A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
POUNDS. THE ALMOND INDUSTRY IS
CALCULATING THAT THEIR SUPPLY
RIGHT NOW AND INVENTORY IS
BETWEEN EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TO NINE HUNDRED MILLION POUNDS.
AT A TIME THAT NORMALLY IS THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION POUNDS. IN THE
CASE OF WALNUTS IN PARTICULAR
BUT FOR ALL OF THESE CLASS WHEN
YOU BACK UP INVENTORY OF
PERISHABLE SPECIALTY CROPS LIKE
THAT. AT THIS TIME OF THE YEAR.
IT WILL HAVE A CASCADING IMPACTS
FOR THE INDUSTRY FOR MULTIPLE
YEARS BECAUSE OF DECREASING
CRISIS AND TRYING TO FIND
ALTERNATIVE MARKETS FOR THOSE
CROPS. IN WALNUTS IN PARTICULAR
WE KNOW THAT CHILE WHICH IS
ANOTHER ONE THAT PRODUCER WILL
START THEIR HARVEST IN APRIL.
AND IT MAY BE MORE DESIRABLE FOR
SOME OF OUR EXISTING CUSTOMERS
IN SOUTHEAST ASIA. TO SORT. OUT
OF CHILEANS THAT. WHAT OF THE
THINGS THAT I'M THAT FRIEND AND-
IN MUTUAL HOW FROM THE FARM WILL
TOUCH ON IT IS NOT ONLY HOW AT
IS BEING IMPACT BY WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE EXPORTS. TRYING
TO GET THEM OUT TRYING TO KEEP
OUR CUSTOMERS TRYING TO KEEP
PRICES AT A SUSTAINABLE LEVEL
BUT ALSO WHAT'S HAPPENING FOR
ALL THOSE MANUFACTURED GOODS.
THAT ARE IN SHORT SUPPLY AND ARE
COMING AT A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
COST I'M SURE MANY OF YOU HAVE
HEARD ABOUT INCREASED COSTS FOR.
HARD SPORT COMMITMENTS ON THE
FERTILIZER AND OTHER INPUTS
CLASS SO WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
CAUSING SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL.
STRAIN ON OUR SYSTEM AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE FIGHTING
HARASSMENT MINISTRATION TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM SUPPLY CHAIN
TASK FORCE. IT HAS BEEN OPEN
DIALOGUE IT HAS BEEN GREAT
COOPERATION AND SEVERAL THAT OF
THE MEASURES THAT WERE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
SIGNED LAST FALL EXECUTIVE
ORDER. NINETEEN TWENTY ONE. HAVE
REAL BEEN FOCUSED WHAT ARE SOME
SHORT TERM THINGS STATE DO TO
HELP SUPPORT THE PROCESS. TO
RELIEVE CONGESTION AMONG THOSE
THINGS WERE WERE- ISSUING
TEMPORARY PERMITS OVERWEIGHT
TRUCKING PERMITS TO MOVE THESE
CONTAINERS. WE DOUBLED THE
COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S LICENSE
TESTING CAPACITY OBVIOUSLY WE
NEED MORE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND PEOPLE APPLYING FOR THOSE
LICENSES THAT THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT DMV DEATHS WITH LIGHT. AND
THEY WERE STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF IDENTIFYING ADDITIONAL STATE
ON PROPERTIES THAT COULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR SHORT TERM. CARGO
CONTAINER STORAGE NEEDS- THIS
PART. HAS BEEN VERY IMPORTANT AS
WE'VE IDENTIFIED ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN VERY
FOCUSED ON SINCE DECEMBER. AND
THAT IS NORMALLY A NUMBER OF
SHIPS WHAT WHAT TAKE CARGO OFF
THAT LONG BEACH AND LA AND THEN
SPEND AN EXTRA TWO DAYS TO COME
UP TO THE PORT OF OAKLAND. THE
PORT OF OAKLAND ACTUALLY HAS
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THOSE JOBS ARE NOT
COMING UP THE COAST ONE OF OUR
FOCUS MESSAGES HAS BEEN TO. IS
TO URGE THE SHIPPERS TO PLEASE
BRING STEPS UP TO THE PORT OF
OAKLAND WHERE ABOUT 50% OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
EXPORTS FELL OUT. ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. BEEN FOCUSED ON THAT AND
MONDAY OF THIS WEEK WE WERE
PLEASED TO SEE THE ANNOUNCEMENT
FROM USDA IN THE PORT OF
OAKLAND. THEY'VE IDENTIFIED A
TWENTY FIVE BAKER EIGHT YARD OFF
TERMINAL THAT CAN BE USED AND
EQUIPPED. FOR CONTAINER AND-
OFFLOADING CONTAINERS AND
CHASSIS IS TO MAKE THEM-AVAILABLE FOR RAPID RELOADING
AND THE DEPLOYMENT TO THE PORT.
THAT'S ONE SMALL STEP IN THE US
IT SHOULD BE UP AND OPERATIONAL
AND MARCH FIRST. IN ADDITION TO
THAT USDA ANNOUNCED THAT THEY
WOULD MAKE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE DOLLAR PAYMENTS. FOR EACH
CONTAINER TO HELP DEFRAY THE
ADDITIONAL COST OR AG EXPORTERS.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE SHORT TERM
THINGS THAT CAN HAPPEN IM GENES
SIROCCO UP AFTER OUTLINED THE
TREMENDOUS PROPOSALS THAT ARE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THESE CAN
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
I'M EXCITED ABOUT ALL OF THEM
BUT I'M ESPECIALLY EXCITED
ABOUT. MAKING THE INVESTMENT TO
FUTURE PROOF OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM
WITH A IT'S A SUSTAINABLE. ITS
MOVEMENT. TRAININGS AND IN CAL
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT. ON ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET ALREADY BEEN
DISPATCHED. AND I WOULD SAY THAT
THE INLAND PORT THAT JEAN
DISCUSSED IS ONE THAT CDFA
CALTRANS AND COPIOUS HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN THOSE ARE THE TYPES
OF LONG TERM VISIONS. THAT WE
ALL NEED TO WORK ON TOGETHER WE
WILL GET THROUGH THIS CURRENT
DISRUPTION IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
ONLY BY WORKING TOGETHER AND I'M
SO PLEASED TO HAVE THE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE DEAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR GIVING ME
SOME TIME. THEY COULD CARE- SO
THANK YOU- MUCH MADAM SECRETARY
AND ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
THE PREVIOUS TWO- THE PALEST-
SECRETARY ROSS AND MR JACOB.
MATHIS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
DIRECT THIS QUESTION TO MISTER
JACOB AND KIND OF JUST REFERRING
BACK TO WHAT- MR SIROCCO ED SAID
IS FAR AS INFORMATION SHARING
YOU KNOW MENTIONING THAT WE'RE
THIRTY YEARS BEHIND IN TRACKING
CONTAINERS- YOU KNOW WOULDN'T
WHEN WE BEGAN DEPLOYMENT IN IRAQ
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE HOURS AT
THE SPEAR HEAD OF THAT AND WE
MOVED. INTO HIGHER ARMY. ACROSS
IN WE TRACKED IN MOVEMENT OF
EVERYTHING ARE ALL THE EQUIPMENT
IN INTO THEATER IN AND BACK OUT.
SO BEING HERE YEARS LATER
LISTENING TO YOU KNOW WE CAN
TRACK PIZZA BOXES BETTER THAN WE
CAN TRACK CONTAINERS IN THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY'S IS KIND
OF FRUSTRATING- FOR MISTER JACOB
HOW DO YOU SEE THE BEST METHOD.
FOR GETTING THE COOPERATION TO
SHARE THAT DATA OF YOU KNOW
BECAUSE IN THE MILITARY WE HAVE
YOU KNOW YOU GOT CLASS THREE YOU
GOT CLASS TWO YOU GOT CLASS FOR.
ON ON WHAT YOU'RE MOVING. WHAT'S
THE BEST WAY TO GO FORWARD FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE TO START DOING
THAT DATA SHARE AND WHAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD DO
WITHIN THE STATE LEGISLATOR. THE
KIND OF HELP PUT SOME PRESSURE
INTO THE MARKET TO DO THAT. YEAH
THANK YOU AND IT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AND-
ACTUALLY THAT- COMPARE AND
CONTRAST TO- THE MILITARY IS A
GOOD ONE- THE- WAY THAT THE
INTERMODAL. SYSTEM WORKS
INTERNATIONALLY IS THAT IT
CREATES VALUE. THROUGH
INTERMODAL ISM BUT WITHOUT
CENTRAL CONTROL- SO ACROSS THE
GLOBE YOU CAN USE THE SAME
EQUIPMENT FOR ALL TYPES OF
DIFFERENT THINGS ON ALL TYPE OF
THE FOR MODES OF TRANSPORTATION
SHIPS TRUCKS TRAINS- IN ANY
COUNTRY. AND WITH JUST THE MAGIC
OF AN INTERCHANGEABLE AND- YOU
CAN HAVE CARGO GOING EVERYWHERE
AND ANYWHERE AND IT'S NOT
CENTRALIZED OBVIOUSLY THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF A CENTRALIZED
MANAGED- SUPPLY CHAIN LIKE IN
THE MILITARY. BUT THAT BEING
SAID THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
AND- DON'T KNOW WHERE THE CARGO
IS I THINK WHAT JIM WAS TALKING
ABOUT WAS THE ABILITY TO
INTERFACE AND BE TRANSPARENT.
WITH END USERS AND- OTHER
PARTIES INCLUDING THE STATE
ANOTHER PUBLIC- ENTITIES AND SO
THAT THAT'S A DIFFERENT RIGHT
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE CARRIER-
WHETHER IT BE AN OCEAN CARRIER
RAIL CARRIER AND A MOTOR CARRIER
THAT DOESN'T KNOW. WHICH BOXES
CARRYING WHERE IT IS. AND HOW
THAT GOING TO PROCEED THROUGH
ITS PORTION OF THAT SUPPLY CHAIN
UNDER A BILL OF LADING- THE
QUESTION IS CAN THE THINGS BE
COORDINATED- AND CAN THAT
INFORMATION BE INTERCHANGED
OUTSIDE THAT PROPRIETARY SPACE.
AND SO I THINK THERE'S TWO
THINGS ABOUT THAT BUT WE'RE
WORKING ON ONE IS- TO OF LA'S
CREDIT MAY ALREADY DO HAVE
TRANSPARENCY INTO A LOT OF THAT
AND THEY PUBLISH IT AND AS JEAN
SAID THAT A LOT OF THAT
INFORMATION IN THERE- IN. THE
PAST WE'VE HAD OURS SENSATION
OTHER ASSOCIATIONS WE HAVE PADS
SEPARATE COMPONENTS OF THESE-
DATA. PUT TOGETHER UNDER OUR OWN
PROPRIETARY AUSPICES SO FOR
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW OUR SITUATION
TRACKS DO WELL TIME- BUT YOU
KNOW A APA THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION WHICH TRACK NATIONAL
TO USE STATISTICS THERE IS NOT A
WAY TO ACTUALLY FORMALIZE ALL OF
THOSE THINGS. IN ONE PLACE WHERE
YOU SEE THE ALL AND NOT OPERATE.
TRANSPARENT EITHER ALL- GET- PUT
INTO IT CUMULATIVE- CLOSE TALK.
DATA SHOW PLACE WHERE IF YOU FOR
WHAT TOWN BUT IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
OUTCOME ON A REAL TIME DAY- THAT
VERY HARD TO DO BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THIS IS TO BE
DISTRIBUTORS AND IT'S TO BE A
NON CENTRALLY CONTROLLED NETWORK
AND THAT'S THE VALUE OF THE
SYSTEM SO THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS PROPOSED- IN THE BUDGET
NOW NOT SECTR RAFI- WOULD LIKE
TO ELABORATED. ON IT BUT- THE
PROPOSAL IN THE- GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO. PREPARE FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL DIGITAL ARCHITECTURE
TO BE- DISCUSSED. IN THE FUTURE
THERE'S NO TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
IN A SPECIFIC DIRECTION FOR WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THAT LANGUAGE AT.
BUT WE REPORT THAT WE THINK
THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO BEGIN TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS AND ON
ARCHITECTURAL BASIS ON A PORT BY
PORT LEVEL. SO EACH PORK AND
START WORKING WITH ITS OWN-
TERMINALS TO DUMB CARRIERS MOTOR
CARRIERS RAIL CARRIERS AND OCEAN
CARRIERS. TO START TO PROVIDE
SOME OF THAT. GREATER
TRANSPARENCY TO THE SYSTEM- BUT
IT IS HARD IT'S NOT CENTRALIZED.
IT'S NOT. THAT PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
THE INFORMATION IT'S MORE ABOUT
MAKING INFORMATION AND A PLACE
WHERE IT'S ACTIONABLE AND SUCH
AN INCIDENT ACTUALLY TRANSPARENT
TO PEOPLE WHO MAY BE MAKING
DECISIONS- PHONE YOUR OPINION. I
MEAN THAT. I'M NOT A BIG FAVOR
THE GOVERNMENT MANDATES BUT BUT
IF WE COULD HAVE A- CENTRAL LOT
LIKE A. VOLUNTARY CENTRALIZED-
GROUP WITHIN BILL. SO YOU GUYS
CAN VOLUNTARY SENT THE
INFORMATION IN REAL TIME. SO
THAT WAY YOU KNOW FOLKS CAN GO
ON L. A. R. R. AGRICULTURE
SHIPPERS ARE MANUFACTURERS AND
EVERYBODY CAN GO IN REAL TIME.
IN IN KNOW EXACTLY WHERE THIS IS
GOING BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING FOR. YOU KNOW ON THE
BUSINESS AND IF YOU HAVE HIGH
SCORED WITHIN A VOLUNTARY SYSTEM
THAN PEOPLE KNOW THIS IS THESE
ARE THE PEOPLE I WANT TO SHIP
WITH VERSUS SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT
IN A VOLUNTARY SYSTEM SO THERE
MIGHT ACTUALLY BE A WAY FOR THE
MARKET TO NATURALLY INCREASE
THEIR RATINGS AND. EXACTLY RIGHT
AT THE VALUE ADD THERE IS AS YOU
DESCRIBED IT AND I THINK WHAT
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE NEXT PANEL
OR PEOPLE THAT ARE FRUSTRATED.
BY THE LACK OF ACTIONABLE
INFORMATION THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO ACTUALLY. MOVE CARGO
FASTER BETTER SMARTER AND LESS
COST. SO WE HAVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF EMPTY CONTAINERS
SITTING ON CHATS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PRIVATE TRUCKING ARTS
IN ADDITION TO THE JAZZ MUSIC
AND- EMPTY THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FACILITATE ALL. TERMINALS BUT IT
IS AN TRANSPARENT IN THE SYSTEM
WHICH TRUCKING ARE THOSE THAT.
ARE THOSE IN WHICH MOTOR
CARRIERS HAVE THE ACCEPTABLE A
QUICK MINUTE. HOW MUCH OF THAT
EQUIPMENT IS ACTUALLY FOOD GRADE
ARE WE WATCH WHICH CONTAINERS
ARE REFRIGERATED. YOU KNOW AND
THEN COORDINATING THOSE THINGS
BACK WITH VETTEL SET THE FAILING
SCHEDULES SO I AM PLEASED TO SAY
AND YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE GET THE
DIRECTOR ONE WE DO HAVE.
CONGESTION AGAIN AT OAKLAND WE
HAVE SEVENTEEN SHIPS WAITING TO
GET IN THERE. BUT IT'S- VERY
FRUSTRATING TO OUR CUSTOMERS IF
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL
SAILING DATE IS BECAUSE THEN
THEY DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY CAN
BRING THEIR CARGO INTO THE
ACTUAL MARINE TERMINAL. WE DON'T
HAVE THE SPACE TO JUST TAKE
CARGO WHENEVER LIKE WE USED TO-
WE'RE ASKING PEOPLE TO HAVE VERY
SPECIFIC PERFORMANCE WINDOWS.
THAT'S VERY FRUSTRATING TO
EXPORTERS- WE UNDERSTAND IT'S
FRUSTRATING BUT IT'S THE ONLY
WAY WE CAN MANAGE LIMITED
RESOURCE WE HAVE RIGHT NOW- SO
DATA TRANSPARENCY AND
COORDINATION THAT RESPECT. FOR
THE VALUE ADD TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
NOT SOMETHING WON'T WORK. THAT'S
THAT'S I'D LIKE TO SEE IS WHAT
OF ALL. CENTRAL SYSTEM WOULD
LOOK. THANK AND THE THEY GIVE US
MATHIS SKIP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AND DONNA WENT TO-
THE PRESENTERS- THAT HAVE
ALREADY PRESENTED- I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS TO- WHOEVER WANTS TO
ANSWER IT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I THINK THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
WE UNDERSTAND- AND YOU GUYS HAVE
ARTICULATED- PRECISELY THE
PROBLEM BUT I ALSO WANT TO HEAR
SOLUTIONS TO THE PROBLEM WITH
WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT. AND MR
SOROKA HEY JEAN HOPE ALL IS
WELL- EIGHTY THOUSAND SHORT
EIGHTY THOUSAND TRUCK DRIVERS
AND- FORTY THOUSAND WORKERS
ETCETERA ETCETERA. HOW DO WE
RECTIFY THAT HOW DO WE SOLVE
THOSE OUTSTANDING ISSUES WITH
THE PLAN THOUGH IT COULD BE
IMPLEMENTABLE THAT WE CAN LOOK
FORWARD TO SO FOR THE NEXT
PRESENTERS AND THOSE WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING AS WELL AS A
SECRETARY PRECIADO- YOU KNOW
MISS ROSS YOUR ARTICULATION BUT
HOW WAS THE SOLUTIONS HONEST WE
UNDERSTAND PROBLEMS BUT WHAT ARE
THE SOLUTION TO THESE PROBLEMS.
THAT WE CAN NOTE AND THAT WE CAN
LOOK AT WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THAT MR O'DONNELL SAID THAT YOU
KNOW SEEK WAS A IS THE ISSUE THE
HOBBIT WE BEGIN TO FEEL THAT-
BANANA LAYER BY LAYER SO THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS SEEK WHAT IT IS IN
FACT AN IMPEDIMENT. TO THE GOODS
MOVEMENTS- OF THE STATE AND SO
WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT AND
LOOKING FOR A PLAN TO ADDRESS
THAT WITHOUT LACKS IN SOME OF
OUR- ENVIRONMENTAL-
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE
SO FAR BUT THIS IS A VERY
UNUSUAL TIED AND SOLUTIONS
SOLUTIONS SOLUTIONS WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT I'LL BE LOOKING
FOR AND NEEDS BUT HIS BODY TO
ALSO GRASS SO THAT WE CAN CREATE
A PLAN TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
AND MISSION IF THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION EXCELLENT
QUESTION AND IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE'RE HERE ON OF THE
THIRD PANEL IS DEDICATED. TO
SOLUTIONS IN FUTURE ISSUES AND
SO OKAY THERE TIME IS OF THE-
WERE HOUR FIFTEEN INTO THIS WE
GOT FORTY FIVE MINUTES LEFT SO I
WANT TO THANK THE PANELISTS- AND
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
SECOND PANEL. WHICH IS THE
IMPACT ON AGRICULTURE- THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY- WHETHER
THEY WILL TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF- PORT CONGESTION TO SPECIFIC
OUR CULTURE INDUSTRIES LIKE TO
INVITE OUR FIRST PANEL TO SPEAK
WAS HERE IN PERSON I BELIEVE
CRAIG- IS A DOER. OF VICE
PRESIDENT GLOBAL SALES AND
MARKETING- WITH- CAMPOS BROTHERS
FARM VIBE IF- I PRONOUNCE YOUR
LAST NAME I APOLOGIZE. THE
PROBLEM. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
. TO REVERSE INTRO DONALD FOR
THE INVITATION TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY REGARDING- CULTURAL
EXPORTS. AND ISSUE THAT
CALIFORNIA PORTS SPECIFICALLY
RELATING TO CALIFORNIA ALMONDS.
MY NAME IS CRAIG DURING VICE
PRESIDENT OF GLOBAL SALES AND
MARKETING AT CAMPUS BROTHERS
FARMS LOCATED IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE FAMILY OWNED
COMPANY AND GLOBAL SERVICE
PROVIDER OPERATING SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE WE WORK TO
CONTINUALLY IMPROVE OUR FARMING
TECHNIQUES AND PROCESSING
OPERATIONS. TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT CONSERVE PRECIOUS
RESOURCES. AS AN ALMOND GROWER
AND HANDLER WE ARE THE LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN CROTHERS CALIFORNIA
BY FAR. IT IS VERY DISCOURAGING
TO US THE CALIFORNIA ALMOND
INDUSTRY AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE THAT OUR EXPORT
SITUATION HAS NOT ONLY. NOT
IMPROVED. BUT IT CONTINUES TO
GET WORSE IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS CONTINUE TO
BE DECIMATED. FOR CAMPUS
BROTHERS FARM 70% OF OUR ALMOND
CROP IS EXPORTED TO OVER SIXTY
COUNTRIES INCLUDING JAPAN THE E.
U. SOUTH KOREA INDIA CHINA AND
THE E. UP IN THE UAE TO NAME A
FEW. WITH EXPORTER FOR THIRTY
SEVEN YEARS SO WE HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN THE COMPLEXITIES
AROUND THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
EXPORT ISSUES. IN ADDITION I AM
A PAST CHAIR OF THE SPECIALLY
CROP TRADE COUNCIL AND CONTINUE
TO SIT ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. OVERALL THE
CALIFORNIA ALMANACS. ALMANACK
SECTOR GENERATES OVER TWENTY ONE
BILLION IN ECONOMIC REVENUE AND
CONTRIBUTES MORE THAN ELEVEN
BILLION TO THE STATE ECONOMYWHILE CREATING OVER ONE HUNDRED
FOUR THOUSAND CALIFORNIA JOBS.
ACCORDING TO CDFA ALMONDS OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S TOP VALUED EAGER
CULTURE EXPORT COMMODITY WITH A
VALUE OF MORE THAN FOUR POINT
NINE BILLION IN FOREIGN SALES IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. WITHOUT SUPPORT
MARKET SO CRITICAL TO OUR
BUSINESS I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THE AG EXPORT CLIMATE IS NOT
LIKE ANYTHING I HAVE EVER SEEN
AND WE ARE EXPERIENCING
OBSTACLES WELL BEYOND OUR USUAL
CHALLENGES. ACCORDING TO THE
RECENT YOU SEE- AB ECONOMICS
ANALYSIS PUBLISHED IN NOVEMBER
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE U.
S. AGRICULTURE USUALLY FILLS AND
THAT ACCESS OR 40% OF ALL LOADED
SHIPPING CONTAINERS LEAVING
CALIFORNIA PORTS. ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF THOSE TYPICALLY CARRY
CALIFORNIA FARM PRODUCTS SHOWING
HOW VITAL CONTAINERIZED SHIPPING
IS TO OUR FARMERS. THE ECONOMICS
ANALYSIS SHOWS THE SHARE OF
EMPTY CONTAINERS LEAVING
CALIFORNIA PORTS BETWEEN MAY AND
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WAS
IT SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. AND HIT
A RECORD 78% IN SEPTEMBER. THAT
IS A HUGE PROBLEM BECAUSE THOSE
EMPTY CONTAINERS ARE NEEDED TO
EXPORT AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
PRE TWENTY TWENTY THE PERCENT OF
EMPTIES WAS 30% ON AVERAGE.
ACCESS TO EXPORT CONTAINERS EVEN
MORE LIMITED GIVEN THE COSTS ARE
EXTREMELY HIGH IN NEW FEES HAVE
BEEN ADDED. THE CONGESTION AND
EXTREME RATES AND FEES
INCENTIVIZE THE SHIPPERS TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA PORTS WITH
EMPTY CONTAINERS PARTICULARLY
AVOIDING THE PORT OF OAKLAND
ALTOGETHER WE'RE A GREAT DEAL OF
OURPRODUCT IS EXPORTED FROM.
THE NUMBER OF VESSELS CALLING O
THE PORT OF OAKLAND HAS DROPPED
SIGNIFICANTLY. AND THE AMOUNT OF
TIME AVAILABLE TO IN GATE HAS
GONE FROM AVERAGE THREE TO FIVE
DAYS TO THIS LAST WEEK A VESSEL
OPENED ONLY FOR FOUR HOURS THIS
PAST WEEK FOR ENGAGING. THE
SUPPLY CHAIN HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
COMPLEX BASE TO OPERATE WITHIN.
HOWEVER WE ARE VERY ALARMED AS
OUR COSTS ARE SKYROCKETING WITH
DETENTION AND DEMURRAGE CHARGES
UP 3100% 60% OF OUR SHIPMENTS
ARE BEING RESCHEDULED OR
CANCELED COMPLETELY. WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONTAINERS THE PAST TWO
MONTHS WITH CONFIRM BOOKINGS
THAT HAD NINE CHANGES TO THE
LAST RECEIVING DATE OR THE AND
GATE. ON AVERAGE WE INCURRED AN
ADDITIONAL CHARGES OF OVER FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CONTAINER.
THESE ARE CHARGES WE CANNOT PASS
ON TO OUR CUSTOMER BUYER IT'S
NOT THEIR FAULT THE VESSEL
DIDN'T PICK UP THE LOAD. AND IT
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT OUR FAULT
EITHER BUT WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY
ZERO RECOURSE WITH THE SHIPPING
COMPANIES. FOR CALIFORNIA
ALMONDS AT LEAST 20% OF OUR
SALES COULD NOT BE COMPLETED
BECAUSE OF OCEAN CARRIER
PRACTICES. SUCH AS THE EXCESSIVE
AND UNREASONABLE BE TENSION TO
DEMERGE CHARGES. OUTRAGEOUS
FREIGHT RATES AND NOT
COMMUNICATING WHICH WAS A BIG
PART OF THE CONVERSATION
ALREADY. IN A TIMELY MANNER. AS
CHAIR RIVAS INDICATED BETWEEN
MAY AND SEPTEMBER TWENTY ONE THE
VALUE OF AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS
FROM CALIFORNIA PLUMMETED BY
SEVENTEEN PERCENT. AMOUNTING TO
ABOUT TWO POINT ONE BILLION IN
LOSSES IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ALMOND INDUSTRY HAS
SEEN MASSIVE PRICE DECLINE
BECAUSE OF EXPORT SHIPMENTS NOT
SHIPPING AS SCHEDULED. EQUAL TO
ANOTHER TWO BILLION DOLLARS THIS
IS MONEY LOST THIS WILL NOT FLOW
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES. THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL CONSEQUENCES IT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED. OUR INDUSTRY
DEPENDS ON INTERNATIONAL
HOLIDAYS AND WE CONTINUE TO MISS
THE SHIPMENT WINDOW TO HIT THOSE
. THIS LACK OF CERTAINTY IS
CAUSING UPHEAVAL FOR CALIFORNIA
ALMOND FARMING FAMILIES AND WE
ARE NOW WHEN YOU'RE INTO A TIME
OF HAVING EXTREME CARRY OUT
LEVELS TO DEAL WITH BECAUSE OF
MIS SHIPMENTS. ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
WE CANNOT BILL AN EXPORT
CUSTOMER WITH WITHOUT HAVING A
BILL OF LADING. CAN GET A BILL
OF LADING UNTIL CONTAINERS
LOADED ON A SHIP. SO EVERY TIME
WE HAVE A VESSEL DELAYED IN
CONTAINERS THAT ARE DELAYED FOR
LOADING WHERE THIS THIS
TRANSLATES INTO HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND BILLING
THAT IS DELAYED SIGNIFICANTLY OR
EVEN CANCELLED. THIS IS
UNSUSTAINABLE IN THE LONG TERM
FOR MANY OF OUR BUSINESSES.
FURTHER GIVEN THE CONGESTION AND
DELAYS ALL THROUGHOUT THE EXPORT
SYSTEM THERE IS A MAJOR RISK OF
PASSED IN DISEASE INFESTATION
WHEN CONTAINER SIT FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME. THIS RESULTS IN
ADDITIONAL EXPENSES AT
DESTINATION THAT CAN RUN INTO
THE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. OR
OUTRIGHT REFUSAL OF THE PRODUCT
BY THE BUYER. OUR COMBINED THE
SITUATION IS UNTENABLE.
ACCORDING TO THE CATO INSTITUTE.
MANY OF THE PROBLEMS AT US PORTS
RESULT FROM INTENTIONAL
DECISIONS MADE YEARS AGO.
DECISIONS BECAUSE IN OUR PORT
SYSTEM TO BADLY LAKE MUCH OF THE
WORLD. THE TWENTY TWENTY WORLD
BANK H. S. MARKET CONTAINER PORT
PERFORMANCE INDEX. SHOWS THAT
NOT ONE U. S. PORT RANKS IN THE
TOP FIFTY GLOBAL PORTS IN TERMS-OF GETTING A SHIP IN AND OUT OF
THE PORT. OAKLAND ACTUALLY CAME
IN THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SECONDS. LA LONG BEACH RATE
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT AND
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THIRD
RESPECTIVELY. YES FOR SOLUTIONS
ON THE FEDERAL SIDE WE SUPPORT A
LIMIT. A LIMIT ON THE PERCENTAGE
OF EMPTY STUDY VASILIS ALLOWED
TO CARRY WHEN DEPARTING THE WEST
COAST PORTS. VESSELS NEED TO BE
REQUIRED TO CALL ON THE PORT OF
OAKLAND AS OPPOSED TO SKIPPING
THE PORT AS SCHEDULED. FURTHER
LEGISLATION IS BEING CONSIDERED
IN CONGRESS TO ESTABLISH
REASONABLE AND FAIR OCEAN
CARRIER PRACTICES CONSISTENT
WITH THE FEDERAL MARITIME
COMMISSION'S. CURRENTLY ON IN
FORCE IMPERATIVE ROLAND A BREACH
IN DETENTION. THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THE SAME
HERE IN THE STATE LEVEL TO
ENSURE EVEN HANDED OCEAN CARRIER
PRACTICES WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
STEPS TAT CAN BE TAKEN TO
MOTORIZED MODERNIZE LONG
CALIFORNIA AND WE HOPE
LEGISLATORS WILL CONSIDER ACTION
TO PARTICULARLY ADDRESS. THE
INFLATED AN UNFAIR FEES I KNOW
THERE'S WORK UNDERWAY TO ADDRESS
MANY OF THESE ISSUES BY THE
FEDERAL STATE OFFICIALS AS WELL
AS THE PORTS AS WE'VE HEARD
TODAY. HOWEVER WE ARE STRONGLY
FEELING THE IMPACTS AS WE SPEAK
AND HONESTLY THE CORRECTIONS
CANNOT HAPPEN FAST ENOUGH. THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO MY
TESTIMONY TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS. I
THANK YOU FOR. THAT TESTIMONY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO THE
SECOND- THE PANELISTS I'LL ASK
MEMBERS TO HOLD THE QUESTIONS
AND TELL ALL OF- THE PANEL
SPEAK. OF WILL BE JOINING US
VIRTUALLY IT'S A MICHAEL PARR
VICE PRESIDENT OF INTERNATIONAL
SALES OF LENTI FAMILY ESTATES.
MISTER PARKER WITH US. I AM YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. VERY GOOD.
GERMAN RIVAS CHAIRMAN DONALD
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME
INSIGHT INTO THE IMPACT OF THE
GLOBAL SHOULD COULD. THAT HAVE
I'M CALIFORNIA WINE EXPORTS
AROUND THE WORLD. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL PART I'M VICE PRESIDENT
OF INTERNATIONAL SALES FOR WENDY
FAMILIES STATES. LOCATED IN
LIVERMORE VALLEY IN EAST BAY
HEARING STEPHENS JUST GO. TWENTY
THE OLDEST FAMILY OWNED WINERY
IN AMERICA FIVE GENERATIONS. ALL
FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED BONDED
WINERIES IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN HE
IS THE THIRTIETH LARGEST WINERY
GET THE TEN TENTH LARGEST
EXPORTER OF PREMIUM WINES AROUND
THE WORLD WE HAVE SUPPORT ACROSS
THE 25% OF OUR ENTIRE PRODUCTION
TO OVER SEVENTY FIVE COUNTRIES.
WITH EXPORT. VALUE POSSIBLY TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. BEFORE TALK
ABOUT YOU. OF THE GLOBAL
SHIPPING. ON CALIFORNIA WINE
EXPORTS LET ME FIRST TALK ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THE CALIFORNIA
WINE INDUSTRY IN OUR OWN
BACKYARD. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA WINE INSTITUTE THE
CALIFORNIA WINE INDUSTRY HAS
FIFTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE ECONOMIC IMPACT. IT ALSO
HAS A ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
BILLION. ARE IMPACTED NATIONAL
THE NATIONAL ECONOMY. THIS IS
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS IN CALIFORNIA AND
TWICE THAT NATIONWIDE. THE
CONTRIBUTES SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE WAGES AND PAYS
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
AND FEDERAL TAXES. LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA EXPORTED ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
ONE GLOBALLY. AS WITH SO MANY
BUSINESSES AROUND THE WORLD THE
GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS HAS
LED TO RISING COSTS AND LONG
DELAYS IN GETTING WIND WORK
EXPORT MARKETS. WHAT IMPACT
THESE TWO WERE FACTORS HOWEVER
WHY BUSINESS OVERSEAS. RISING
SHIPPING COSTS ARE HAVING A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON RETAIL
PRICES ARE EXPORT MARKETS. IN
ORDER TO OFFSET GLOBAL FREIGHT
RATES THAT ARE UP SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER THIS TIME LAST YEAR OUR
REPORTERS RAISING PRICES TO
THEIR RETAILERS AND RESTAURANT
CUSTOMERS. AS A RESULT WE ARE
BEGINNING TO LOSE MARKET SHARE
TO INTERNATIONAL COMPETITORS
THAT ARE NOT FACING THESE EXTRA
COSTS. RICH SPANISH ITALIAN AND
AUSTRALIAN WINES ARE COUNTING ON
THESE NEW OPPORTUNITIES. BINDING
THE- DELAYS IN GETTING OUR WANTS
TO EXPORT MARKETS ARE RAMPANT
WHAT USED TO TAKE ONE TO TWO
WEEKS TO PROCESS A WIDE ORDER
GET PICKED UP FOR SHIPMENT IS
NOW TAKING THREE TO FOUR MONTHS.
WHETHER THE BECAUSE OF THE
SHORTAGE OF SHIPPING CONTAINERS.
OR SECURING SPACE ON VESSEL IT
IS A RESULT IN THOUSANDS OF
CASES THE LINES THAT ARE SITTING
IN OUR WINERY WAREHOUSE AT THIS
VERY MOMENT INSTEAD OF BEING ON
ROUTE TO INTERNATIONAL
DESTINATIONS. THESE DELAYS IN
SHIPMENTS B. TO STOCK OUT
SITUATIONS ON WORLDWIDE RETAILER
SHELVES RESTAURANT WANTED LISTS.
THOSE RETAILERS AND RESTAURANTS
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN STRONGER
WINDS NOW WE'RE SELLING
SOMETHING ELSE ONCE YOU LOSE A
PLACEMENT. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO GET BACK. RECENT SHIPMENT ARE
ALSO CALL LOSS SALES OPPORTUNITY
. JUST THIS WEEK COST THE U. K.
HIS KEY. CALIFORNIA Y. PROMOTION
DUE TO LACK OF INVENTORY. THE
WINDS WERE ORDERED SIX MONTHS
AGO AND IT'S STILL NOT ARRIVED.
THIS PROMOTION WAS TO BE HELD IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WINE INSTITUTE AND REPRESENTS
LOST VALUE OF SEVERAL THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS. THIS IS THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF ONLY ONE LOSS SALES
OPPORTUNITY WITH ONE RETAILER IN
ONE COUNTRY. IN DISSIPATED
SHIPMENT DELAYS ARE ALSO
CHANGING THE WAY OUR IMPORTERS
ARE WARMING WINDS. MANY OF THEM
HAVE CHANGED THEIR EFFICIENT
ORDERING PROCESS FROM JUST IN
TIME TO JUST IN CASE. WITH
LOOMING UNCERTAINTY AS TO
WHETHER THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET
THEIR HANDS ON THE WINES THESE
OF ARE OVER ORDERING. IN
ANTICIPATION OF NOT RECEIVING
THE STOCKS WHEN THEY NEED THE-
SIMILAR TO THE PANTRY LOADING
MENTALITY THAT INFLUENCED
HOUSEHOLDS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
PEOPLE WANT TO FEEL PREPARED TO
WEATHER UNEXPECTED EVENTS. AS A
RESULT OF THIS OUR OWN INVENTORY
LEVELS AT THE WINERY HAVE BECOME
DANGEROUSLY LOW. IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO TELL CUSTOMERS YOU
ARE LOW ON INVENTORY WHEN THERE
ARE THOUSANDS OF CASES OF WINE
SITTING IN YOUR HOUSE WAITING
FOR PICK UP BY FREE FORWARD.
READ DELAYS AND RISING COSTS ARE
NOT THE ONLY. FACTOR AFFECTING
ADULT ONE AFFECTING OUTBOUND
SHIPMENTS AROUND THE WORLD. THE
ALSO AFFECTED PRODUCTION E. END
OF THE ONE BUSINESS. EXTRA COSTS
AN EXTENDED LEAD TIMES ALL
MATERIALS HAVE GONE UP WITHIN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WILL BEGIN
BOTTLING OR TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE VINTAGE WINES.
WINERIES ARE DESPERATE TO SECURE
ORDERS FOR GLASS LABELS COURTS
IN CARDBOARD. DISRUPTIONS IN
DELIVERIES OF THESE COMPONENTS
CAN THROW OFF BOTTLING TIMELINES
FOR THOSE WINERIES THAT NEED TO
OUTSOURCE BOTTLING LINES THIS
CRUCIAL IN CANCELLATION FEES
WERE PAID IN PRIOR PRICES TO
SECURE A GUARANTEE BOTTLING DATE
. AND OF COURSE DELAYED
SHIPMENTS RESULT IN LOST
REVENUES WHEN HE COULD HAVE
SHIPPED PERCENT MORE WIND IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE IF WE COULD
HAVE SECURED THE FREIGHT PICKUP
ASSIGNMENTS. IN CONCLUSION IF WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THE
CALIFORNIA WINE INDUSTRY COULD
FACE LONG TERM EXPORT MARKET
SHARE DECLINE. IN REDUCE
REVENUES THAT FINANCIALLY
SUPPORTS SO MUCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. THE
DECISIONS YOU MAKE IN SACRAMENTO
WILL AFFECT FOUR THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED BONDED WINERIES IN THE
FIVE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED GRAPE
GROWERS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER PAR-
APPRECIATE THAT TESTIMONY- AND
FINALLY THE- FINAL SPEAKER FOR
THIS PANEL DESCRIPTION IS CHRIS
CRUTCHFIELD CEO OF AMERICAN
COMMODITY COMPANY. I BELIEVE HE
IS HERE IN PERSON. WELCOME TO
SUCCESSFUL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF BONTA BOTH OF THE CHAIRMAN
AND- ALL OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS- FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY
AS A GERMAN MENTION- MY NAME IS
CHRIS CARTWHEELS I'M CEO OF- ECC
RICE- MILLING AND EXPORTING
COMPANY ON OUT OF COLUSA COUNTY
. IN ADDITION TO LEADING MY
COMPANY I ALSO SERVE ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION IN
THE USA RICE MILLERS ASSOCIATION
THE USA RICE FEDERATION. AND I
HAVE RECENTLY BEEN APPOINTED TO
THE NEWLY CREATED FEDERAL
MARITIME COMMISSION'S NATIONAL
SHIPPER ADVISORY COMMITTEE. I
WEAR CONTACTS THE CALIFORNIA
RICE INDUSTRY PRODUCES RICE ON
ABOUT HALF A MILLION ACRES-
RIGHT HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALUE. VALLEY TRANSLATING INTO
NEARLY TWO MILLION METRIC TONS
OF RICE- FURTHER I KNOW THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT POUNDS
HERE TODAY SO. JUST TO PUT THAT
A LITTLE BIT OF PERSPECTIVE. I
JUST OVER FORTY BILLION POUNDS
OF RICE- IMITA EXPORTED ABOUT
50% TO OVER SEVENTY FIVE
COUNTRIES ALL OVER THE WORLD.
ANYWHERE WHEN YOU TRAVEL OUTSIDE
OF THE U. S. AND YOU CONSUME
SUSHI- AND YOU'RE NOT IN
NORTHEAST ASIA YOU'RE PROBABLY
EATING RICE GROWN RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THESE EXPORTS ARE
FACILITATED THROUGH THREE POINT
THREE PORTS- STOCKTON WEST
SACRAMENTO. AND OAKLAND. OUR
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED AT ALL THREE OF THESE
FACILITIES THE EFFECTS OF THIS
CRISIS ARE SIGNIFICANT. NOT JUST
FOR MILLS LIKE MINE AND THE
PEOPLE ARE EMPLOYED. BUT ALSO
WITH ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE
INDIVIDUAL GROWER- LET ME GIVE
YOU A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE FOR MY
COMPANY AND SEVERAL OF MY OTHER
MALE COLLEAGUES IN HERE IN THE
STATE. THE HIGHEST VALUE RICE WE
EXPORT. ISN'T BRANDED RETAIL
WHOLESALE AND FOODSERVICE BAGS.
TO MARKETS OF SOUTH KOREA JAPAN.
AND THE MIDDLE EAST AND IT'S ALL
SHIPPED IN CONTAINERS. THEN IT
GOES OUT IN PACKAGES LIKE THESE
. WHILE YOU MAY NOT RECOGNIZE
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE ON THESE
PACKAGES ONE THING YOU PROBABLY
DO RECOGNIZES CALIFORNIA. AS A
RESULT OF THE SHIPPING CRISIS
HOWEVER THIS ALL OF THIS
BUSINESS IS DRIED UP. CURRENTLY
OUR INDUSTRY. DOES NOT HAVE A
BACKLOG OF CONTAINERS. SOMERS
DUE TO THE NEAR IMPOSSIBILITY OF
SECURING BOOKINGS. AND WHEN WE
DO WE ARE TAGGED WITH EXCESSIVE
DIVERGENT DETENTION FEES. REYES
BOUND FOR THESE MARKETS IS NOW
SHIPPED OUT OF THE IMPORTS OF
WEST SACRAMENTO AND STOCKTON IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED POUND
JUNIOR TOOK BAGS. UNBRANDED AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY WITH NO DIRECT
ACCESS TO OUR CONSUMERS. AFTER
DECADES OF EFFORT AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS PROMOTING BRANDED
CALIFORNIA RICE TO OUR CUSTOMERS
IN CHAPTER IN JAPAN IN IN SOUTH
KOREA. THEY NOW CANNOT FIND AN
EASILY IDENTIFIABLE PACKAGE
PRICE FROM THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY
. HOWEVER AT LEAST WE CAN STILL
EXPORT TO ASIA ALBEIT AND BOOK
BAGS AND ON MARCH BUT MORE CHIPS
CONVERSELY OUR INDUSTRY HAS LOST
MORE THAN 80% OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND METRIC TONNE
MARKET. THROUGHOUT THE MIDDLE
EAST AND NORTH AFRICA. BECAUSE
THESE MARKETS CAN ONLY RECEIVE
CONTAINERIZED SHIPMENTS THEY'RE
NOT. THEIR PORTS ARE NOT SET UP
TO RECEIVE. TWELVE FIFTEEN
TWENTY THOUSAND TONE BOTH PRICE
SHIPMENTS. CALIFORNIA RICE IN
THESE MARKETS HAS LARGELY BEEN
REPLACED BY CHINESE AND RUSSIAN
RICE. THE LOSS OF MARKETS AND
CONVERSION FROM CONSUMER TO BOTH
PACKAGES RESULTS IN MUCH LOWER
PRICES AND AS A HUGE FINANCIAL
IMPACT ON OUR ENTIRE INDUSTRY.
WE ESTIMATE THAT. MORE THAN
NINETY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF VALUE HAS ALREADY BEEN
STRIPPED FROM OUR INDUSTRY JUST
THIS CROP YEAR WHICH IS ONLY
THREE AND A HALF MONTHS ALL.
THIS WAS NOT ONLY IMPACTS MY MIL
AND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE I CAN
THE PULLEY. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
THE PARKING PACKAGE LIKE THIS A
TWO POUND BAG TAKES QUITE A FEW
MORE PEOPLE TEND TO RUN THE
OPERATE THEN THE OPERATOR TO RUN
THE AUTO LOADER FOR A TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED POUND JUMBO
TOTE BAG. IT ALSO TRANSLATES
DIRECTLY INTO LOWER PRICES FOR
FARMERS ARE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
FAMILY FARMERS. THAT THEY GET
FOR THEIR CROP. FINALLY I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE SHIPPING OUT
OF THE INLAND PORTS HAS BECOME
MORE CONGESTED AND MORE
EXPENSIVE AS MAJOR IMPORTERS
INCLUDING WALMART AND COSTCO ARE
SHIFTING THEIR IMPORT CARGO OUT
OF THE PORTS OF LOS ANGELES AND
LONG BEACH AN INTERIM IN. INLAND
PORTS. INCLUDING IMPORTING RICE
. DIRECTLY COMPETING WITH OUR
FAMILY FARMERS HERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THERE ARE
ACTIONS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN TAKE. FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO ENCOURAGE
OCEAN CARRIERS TO EXPORT
CONTAINERS FILLED WITH
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
RATHER THAN SIMPLY SENDING THEM
BACK TO ASIA EMPTY. WE ALSO
SUPPORT ALL EFFORTS TO PROHIBIT
THOSE SAME CARRIERS FROM
CHARGING EXPORTERS FOR DELAYS
AND RESCHEDULING OF DELIVERIES
NOT CAUSED BY THE EXPORTER. LET
ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF JUST
HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS BEGUN TO
SHIPPING CONTAINERS JUST LAST
YEAR IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE MY COMPANY WAS PAYING ONE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR A TWENTY FOOT CONTAINER. TO
GO FROM OAKLAND TO AQABA JORDAN
THIS IS ONE OF THE MAJOR ROUTES
NOT ONLY FOR MY COMPANY BUT NOT
FOR MANY CALIFORNIA RICE MILLS.
JORDAN IMPORTS OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND TONS OF CALIFORNIA RICE
EVERY YEAR. TODAY THAT SAME
ROUTE. A CONTAINER COST FIVE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
EXCESSIVE DEMURRAGE AND
DETENTION FEES WHICH ARE ALWAYS
CARDS AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
MOMENT- SITUATION MENTIONED-
THESE WINDOWS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED EARLIER. CAN GET DOWN
TO FOUR HOURS THAT CAN BE A LIVE
LOAD. THAT IS GOING DOWN TO
OAKLAND FROM MY MAIL IN MY TEAM
IS INFORMED WHILE THE CONTAINERS
ON THE ROAD THAT NOT ONLY IS THE
ENGAGE. NOT TOMORROW. THE END
DATE DEADLINE IS THREE O'CLOCK
THIS AFTERNOON. WELL IF YOU'VE
EVER BEEN DOWN TO THE PORT OF
OAKLAND YOU CAN'T WAIT IN LINE
IN THREE HOURS HI AND YOU
CERTAINLY CAN'T HIT A WINDOW
LIKE THAT. THESE FEES ARE
CONTROLLABLE IN THE END SHOULD
BE BROUGHT BACK INTO LINE WITH
HISTORIC LEVELS. IN THE SHOULD
NOT BE USED AS A SOURCE OF
ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR OCEAN
CARRIERS AND AN INDUSTRY. THAT
IS SEEING ALL TIME RECORD HIGH
PROFIT MARGINS. SECONDLY WE
STRONGLY CONDEMN TROLLING
COURAGE CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
OUR PORTS. FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE FAR BEHIND THOSE
OF ASIA. AND THE MAJORITY OF THE
REST OF THE DEVELOPED WORLD. WE
NEED TO MODERNIZE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO
REFLECT REMAIN COMPETITIVE LONG
AFTER THIS CURRENT CRISIS IS
BEHIND US. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
VERY ENCOURAGING. TO ME TO SEE
THAT THE ASSEMBLY IS ENGAGING IN
LEADERSHIP ON AN ISSUE THAT IS
UNTIL RECENTLY HAS FRANKLY BEEN
INVISIBLE. WHILE PORTS
TRANSPORTATION AND LOGISTICS
HAVE CERTAINLY COME INTO THE
SPOTLIGHT DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THE REALITY IS THIS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS BEEN AILING
FOR A LONG WHILE. IT IS HIGH
TIME TO GET IT HEALTHY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF AGRICULTURE AND THE
BENEFIT OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER CRUTCHFIELD AND NOW WE
HAVE- QUESTION COMMENT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE APPLE
WATCH THIS JUST A COMET- I WAS
WELL I THINK THE BODY FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. AND LISTENING TWO I
WANT TO THANK MR GIVES AS IT AS
THE LEAVES OF TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT THIS FIX RIGHT BUT YOU HEARD
THE FRUSTRATION THAT AS THE
SPEAKERS. IT'S SCARY IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
SIT HERE AND SAY HEY YOU KNOW
WHAT. WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE MOTIONS. DAHLE WE DON'T JUST
FEED- THIS STATE OR THIS COUNTRY
REPEAT THIS WORLD AND I'M
HEARING MORE MORE OF FARMERS
GOING IT'S USUALLY BEEN
GENERATIONAL RIGHT NOT THEN IT
IS A MYTH THAT PEOPLE THINK THAT
FARMERS ARE RICH RIGHT AND I
HATE HEARING THAT BECAUSE I'M
FROM AG COMMUNITY I THINK I SEE
IT HERE. WHAT THEY DO I'M
HEARING MORE MORE OF THE FAT OF
THE KIDS SAYING I'M NOT GONNA DO
THAT I'M NOT GOING TO DO WHAT MY
PARENTS DID IT'S TOUGH. AND I'M
JUST THANKFUL FOR YOU GUYS FOR
BEING HERE BECAUSE I HEAR IT IN
YOUR GUISES VOICE I HEAR THE
FRUSTRATION. AND IT'S SCARY AND
SCARY FOR OUR ECONOMY. LAST YEAR
THIS YEAR IT'S BEEN GOOD FOR THE
STATE BUT WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
DOMINO EFFECT. YOU KNOW AND THAT
DOMINO EFFECT WORK IT'S GOING TO
PAY BACK WE'RE GOING TO BE IN
THE HOLE. WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
THE SOLUTION AND A FIX AND A
QUICK FIX. BECAUSE WHAT THE
ACTIVITY DOES. IS NOT JUST FOR.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- OR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. IT'S FOR
EVERYONE AND- I JUST WANT TO SAY
IT'S MORE OF A COMMENT I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU GUYS FOR
COMING UP HERE AND LET IN OUR
BODY HERE TO HEAR YOUR
FRUSTRATION. THANK YOU. THANK U.
S. NUMBER AND THEY CAN. HM THANK
YOU SEVEN NUMBER- MAJORITY
LEADER RACE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THAT WAS THE WORD THAT
KEPT COMING THROUGH IS I HEARD
YOUR TESTIMONY IS THE
FRUSTRATION IT'S REAL ALSO FROM
THE PANELISTS ON ON THE TV IT'S
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR THE TWO OF
YOU TO BE HERE TODAY BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S MORE. WEEK IT'S
PALPABLE THE FRUSTRATION IS
PALPABLE AND I THINK THAT IT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY WE HEAR IT
OFTEN FROM OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE MORE INVOLVED IN THIS I'M
INLAND. AND I AM INVOLVED WITH
THE LOGISTICS ASPECT OF IT BUT
TO HEAR FROM OUR COLLEAGUES
REGARDING THEIR FRUSTRATION. NOW
TO HAVE IT. HAVE YOU SPEAK ABOUT
IT AND IT SO ELOQUENTLY AND SO.
IN SUCH A RAW WAY- IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HEAR AND I
AGREE WITH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA
PUT THE WHAT THAT THIS THIS WAS
IMPORTANT WAS IMPORTANT FOR ALL
OF US TO BE HERE. I THINK THAT
IT'S WOOD ONE THING THAT IS
CLEAR TO ME IS THAT AS WE LOOK
FOR A SOLUTION. YOU ALL HAVE TO
BE AT THE TABLE IT ISN'T A
SOLUTION IT'S GOING TO BE DONE
BY A BUNCH OF POLITICIANS- OF
SITTING BEHIND A DESK TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO. IT'S
GOING TO BE TO ENGAGE THOSE WHO
ARE IMPACTED BY WHAT IS
HAPPENING. THE IN THE EARLIER-
PRESENTATION BY MR SIROCCO THE
ONE THING THAT THE AND ITS BEEN
BROUGHT UP A NUMBER OF TIMES IS
THE FACT THAT WE NEED TO IMPROVE
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN. DIGITALIZATION
THE FACT THAT WE ARE THIRTY
YEARS BEHIND OTHER NATIONS IS
UNBELIEVABLE TO ME QUITE
FRANKLY. ARE WE ARE SO AHEAD. IN
SO MANY WAYS BUT TO KNOW THAT
THAT WE ARE THIRTY YEARS BEHIND
OTHER OTHER NATIONS. IS AS
UNACCEPTABLE- BUT WE NOW SEE THE
EFFECTS OF BEING SO FAR BEHIND.
IT THEN I AYE DADDY SINCERELY
APPRECIATE. THAT YOU HAVE TAKEN
THE TIME TO COME HERE TO
PRESENTED TO US THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM MAJORITY LEADER- AND
SO WITH THAT WANT TO THANK THE
PANELISTS- YOU KNOW AGAIN WE'RE
PRESSED FOR TIME IS A ONE TO GET
TO OUR FINAL PANEL OF. THE DAY-
AND SO WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO CHANNEL DONALD TO DO
SELF RESPONSE THANK YOU AND I
TO. THANK YOU HIS REELECTION. SO
WELCOME DANNY PRESIDENT OF THE
CAL. ASSOCIATION OF PORT
AUTHORITIES OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
KAPPA. AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE PORT OF OAKLAND HOLY JOINING
US REMOTELY TO DISCUSS WITH THE
PORT IS DONE TO EASE CONGESTION.
THIS PANELS ENTITLED SOLUTIONS
AND FUTURE ISSUES. SEMESTER ONE
WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
PROCEED PLEASE. SORT OF GRAPHIC
I REPRESENTATION OF WHAT OPEN
AND WHY BECAUSE I WANTED TO. PAY
ATTENTION TO THE OPERATOR WHERE
MICE CLOSER IS THAT DEEP YELLOW
SPACE OF THE TERMINAL IN THE
PORT OF OAKLAND. OF SECRETARY
ROSS IN THE INDUSTRY I REPRESENT
AS I'VE MENTIONED THE CALIFORNIA
PORTS. HANI MODERNIZING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I POINT THIS
OUT BECAUSE THAT GOES SPACE
RIGHT THERE RIGHT NOW COULD BE A
PORT TERMINAL BUT IT'S NOT WHY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT PAID WE'VE HAD
NOT ECONOMY INVESTMENT WE NEED
TO EXPAND THAT SPACE BUT
CONTAINERS TOWARDS FOR TOMORROW
OPERATIONS. AND WE DON'T I WILL
TALK ABOUT THE LAST AS CUT IN
OUR SYSTEM RIGHT NOW FOR
EXPORTERS. WE HAVE SPACE HERE
THAT IS NOT MODERNIZE IN IT IS.
TO BE PORTABLE SPACE CURRENTLY
S. CERTAINLY ARE THE BEST MEN'S
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS MAKING THE
PORTS IS GOING TO HELP US CATCH
UP. I JUST WANT TO POINT AS TO
WHY OUR PORTS ARE STILL BEHIND
IN TERMS OF OUR INVESTMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE HERE CALIFORNIA.
WE HAD NOT HEARD OF THE ABOUT-
WHY THE- ACTOR ARE HAVING ISSUES
AND ESPECIALLY WITH PORTAL. IT'S
NOT GIVE YOU IS- TO UP THE AT
ONE THAT SERVICE FOR EXPORTERS
THAT PORT. I HERE IS THAT YOU
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE AS OF RIGHT
NOW RIVERSIDE BROTHER SEVEN
VESSELS BERTH. AT EIGHT ANCHOR
SIX DRIFTING HOWEVER THAT DOES
NOT QUITE- GIVE THE EXPORT I
CAUGHT EXPORTERS ANY COMFORT SHE
WAS WAITING OUT AT THE AT THE
BANK BECAUSE WHY A LOT OF THAT
IS THE IMPORTS LARA'S BAPTIST
BASEBALL EXPORTERS ON THOSE
SHIPS AS THEY GO OUT- WE HAD-
AND PART OF THE ISSUE AS
MENTIONED BEFORE IS EIGHT OF OUR
TWENTY FIVE HISTORICAL WEEKLY
SERVICES ARE NOT BYPASSING OPEN.
DUE TO THE FACTORS THAT THAT
MANY OF OUR SPEAKERS BEFORE ME
SO I SPOKE UP- WE HAVE SIXTY TWO
BATTLE CALLS IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE VERSUS NINETY
FOUR ID TWENTY. TWENTY- D.
TWENTY TWO. SO WHAT IS THE
IMPACT THAT YOU HAVE A EXPORTS.
WE HAVE HEARD OVER AND OVER
AGAIN THAT ARE EXPLORED.
PARTNERS I SAID TO CALL THE OAK
PORTABLE OAKLAND IS ABOUT FOUR
FOUR FOR AGRICULTURE EXPORTER
FOR LARGE SEGMENTS OF OUR EXPORT
COMMITTEE AT COMMUNITY YES AS WE
COMPARED DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE VERSUS DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY THROUGH THE PORT OF
OAKLAND. WE SEE THE REDUCTION IN
THE VOLUME. I THOSE ARE SIGN
FINAL THE PERSON. TRY NOT MUCH
AS THIRTY FIVE EIGHT MONTHS
THIRTY FIVE AND YOU HEARD FROM
THE RICE INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVE. YEAH THEY HAVE
THE REDUCTION IN EXPORTING RICE
OF 73% TO A PORTABLE- THAT IS A
FIGURE THAT IS. TRANSLATING TO
THE IMPACT OF YOU HEARD
INTERESTED ECONOMICS AND
BUSINESS LOSSES THAT ARE
SUFFERING. NEXMO OVERALL THE TOP
AB KAMANI VOLUMES DOWN SIX. YEAR
OVER YEAR TWENTY ONE VERSUS
TWENTY. THE LAST WILL APPOINT I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THIS IS VERY
CALIFORNIA. CENTRIC CONCERN
HERE.BUT YOU'VE ALSO HEARD
FIGURES IF YOU LOOK AT
NATIONWIDE. ADD EXPERT ACTUALLY
HAVE GONE UP. IT'S GOING TO
PANDEMIC. YET EXPORTS TO
CALIFORNIA'S GOING DOWN. AND
THAT SEEMS LIKE A PARADOX TO US
BUT NOT SO MUCH IF YOU CONSIDER
THAT CALIFORNIA'S A WHOLE IS
LOOKING LOSING EXPORT MARKET
SHARE. IN OTHER WORDS AG EXPORTS
GOING TO CALIFORNIA PORTS OF
GOING DOWN. WHILE THE VOLUME TO
EAST COAST PORT GATES WAYS ARE
GOING UP AND THAT EXPLAINS WHY
EXPORTS GOING UP EVEN THOUGH IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE LOSING THAT
MARKET SHARE THAT CERTAINLY IS A
CONCERN TO EXPORT COMMITTEE.
YEAH COMMITTEE BUT AS WELL I
THINK AS CALIFORNIA AND- THIS
LEGISLATURE WE OUGHT TO BE
THINKING ABOUT WHY WE'RE HAVING
THAT PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY. WHAT DO WE DO
ABOUT IT. SECRETARY ROSS AND I
GIVE A LOT OF THINGS TO HER AND
ALSO BILL BIZ DIRECTION MYERS IS
ALWAYS CAL STUDY TRANSPORTATION
DEPARTMENT FOR HELPING US GET TO
WHERE WE ARE. AS MENTIONED
BEFORE ON MONDAY THE USDA
AGRICULTURE DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED
AND PROGRAM AT THE PORT OF
OAKLAND IN WHICH WE ARE NOW
LAYING DOWN A TEMPORARY A
CONTAINER STORAGE AND PARKING
SPACE TWENTY TWO ACRES. HOW DOES
THAT HELP THEY REALLY RELIEVES
THESE SORT OF EMPTY CONTAINERS
PARKED ON TERMINALS TO RELIEVE
THE OVERCROWDING SO IT MAKES
MORE SPACE. FOR EXPORTERS TO GO
GET THEIR CONTAINERS CONTAINERS.
SO HEY GET HAVE CONTAINERS FOR
THEIR COMMODITY EXPORTS. AT THIS
FACILITY TRYING TO FIND TWO
ACRES. MAN POOR ONLY WE'RE GOING
TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED FORTY
REFRIGERATED CONTAINER PLUGS FOR
THOSE REFRIGERATED AND CHILLED
PRODUCTS GOING TO THE PORT OF
OAKLAND. WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
OPERATOR THE COST OF THIS TO THE
CONTAINER TO USE IT IS A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
CONTAINER WE ESTIMATE. HOWEVER
THE USDA HAS COMMENTED SAID-
THOSE EXPORT AG EXPORTERS WANTED
TO USE YARD CAN GET THAT
REIMBURSED ARE INCENTIVIZED TO
THE TO THE USDA A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS PER CONTAINER. SO
IN OTHER WORDS ARE REIMBURSING
ANY COSTS USES CONTAINER SPACE
THIS IS A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND THE PORT OF OAKLAND. AND
ACCORDING TO THE PRESS RELEASE
BY USDA THIS MAY SERVE AS A
MODEL FOR OTHER POINTS AS WELL
AND AGAIN WE THANK THE US
SECRETARY ROSS AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES WHILE. HAVING COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION THAT THE OTHER
FEDERAL PARTNERS ARE ENGAGING
THEM. WHAT ARE THE BENEFITS OF
THIS PROGRAM THERE'S NO
APPOINTMENTS REQUIRED MULTIPLE
COACHING CARRIERS EQUIPMENT
AVAILABLE THERE IT'S AVAILABLE
TO ALL AREAS NOT ANY SINGLE
TERMINAL CARRIER. UP FASTER
TRUCK TURN TIMES MORE
FLEXIBILITY. ONE VESSEL
SCHEDULES CHANGE. AND ALSO WE
ARE POOREST BUT INCENTIVE TO
AGRA EXPORTERS. I ONGOING NEEDS
WE NEED MAINTAIN THE CARGO REESE
WHEN IS THAT A FORM WE NEED TO
GO. WHEN THEY HAVE WEEKS TO GET
THIS IN A OFFICE. WE TRY TO
BUILD SPACE ON I HOPE AS CALLS
TO EXPORT CARGO THIS IS A
PARTICULAR. WHEN THERE ARE
SCHEDULED SHIPPING VESSELS
COMING INTO THE PORT ANNOUNCED
SO THAT EXPORTERS DON'T EVEN GET
THE NEWS THAT THERE IS A SPACE
AVAILABLE AND THEY JUST TURN
AROUND AND TO ACT ALTHOUGH THE
IMPORTS AND GO BACK TO ASIA. WE
NEED TO HAVE. RETURN TO THE OAK
SIR ROUTES. THE SHIPPING LINES.
TO PARTICULARLY SOUTH. EAST ASIA
WHERE A LOT OF THE EXPORTS ARE
NOW HAVING NO SPACE ON THE
SHIPPING LINES. ADDITIONAL
PARTNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES WITH
THE STATE AS I MENTIONED VERY OF
UP FRONT. WHAT THE MATH WE NEED
FUNDING FOR MODERNIZING ALL
PORTS IN THE FUTURE SO THAT WE
UTILIZE. MAXIMIZE YOU ARE
UTILITY OF OUR OF OUR CAPACITY
AT THE PORTS AND ALSO MAKE IT
MORE EFFICIENT. SO WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S JOHNNY BUDGET
BLUEPRINT WHICH SUPPLIES THAT
MONEY THAT YOU LIST THE HERE
THAT WE HOPE TO- WE'LL USE
SUFFICIENTLY TO MODERNIZE OUR
PORTS AS MENTIONED MANY TIMES.
THE TRICORDER HENCE MY PROGRAM
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH AS MENTIONED BEFORE SO I
WON'T BELABOR THAT. LASTED LATE
REPORT PRIORITIES WE NEED TO
HAVE MAGICAL CAPACITY IN
RENEWABLE ENERGY RESILIENCY
INITIATIVES TO REALLY GROWING UP
PORTS NOT ONLY JUST TO MAKE IT
LAST ADMISSION. OF PARTICULAR
MATTER MISSION ALSO MORE
ENVIRONMENT FRIENDLY BUT YOU
MAKE IT MOVE FASTER AND MORE
EFFICIENTLY. AND AGAIN WE NEED
TO MODERNIZE I'M MERENBERG
TERMINALS AND WAREHOUSING
FACILITIES. TO SERVE OUR EXPORT
COMMUNITIES. I THINK TOWARD MEN
BECAUSE THE NEXT SPEAKER AND THE
REV US. IS HERE THAT ARE THERE
ARE. FOR LIKE PORTLAND AT THE
OAKLAND AND STOCKTON TO REALLY
FIND PARTNERSHIPS TO OFFER MORE
CHOICES MODALITIES AND ALSO
INLAND PORT POSSIBILITIES
BETWEEN THE PORT OF OAKLAND AND
PUT A STOP TO. IT WAS A KIND OF
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE NEED TO
BUILD AS WE GO FORTH FOR
SOLUTIONS. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR GIVING ME AND I WILL-
YOU KNOW THE TIME OF YOUR THE
FLOOR NOW THANK YOU CHAIR. FOR
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER OUT
WHEN AND- YOU KNOW AGAIN
FOCUSING ON SOLUTIONS IN FUTURE
ISSUES A SECOND- THE PANELISTS
HERE WITH US IN PERSON IS THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU. FEDERATION JAMIE
JOHANNSON- JAMIE IS ALWAYS GREAT
TO SEE YOU AND- IT'S ALL YOURS.
THANK YOU AT OR EVEN AND THANK
YOU- CHAIR O'DONNELL AND THE
REST OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE FOR TAKING A SAUNA
JIM JOHANNSON PRESS THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. I'M ALSO
A FARMER AND BUTTE COUNTY
FARMING OLIVE AND CITRUS. AMONG
THE MANY PROBLEMS HE HAD IN THIS
IS TO YOU SEE A TRIPLE WHAMMY
BUT NOW WITH EXPORTS IN THE KOBE
AND STILL RECOVERING FROM THAT
OF COURSE DROUGHT AND THEN OF
COURSE THE TRADE WAR. I MEAN
IT'S BECAUSE BEFORE ME HAVE
COVERED IT SO I'LL BE BRIEF I
KNOW YOU'RE RUNNING ON SHORT ON
TIME. BUT I KNOW THAT WILL HAVE
CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS- JUST IN
CONTEXT OF WHAT WE'RE FACING
HERE CALIFORNIA FARMERS LOST TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
EXPORT SALES- BETWEEN MAY AND
SEPTEMBER. YOU MAY REMEMBER-
MEDIA COVERAGE ON A CHINESE THAT
THE CHINA TRADE WAR. IN WHICH
AGRICULTURE AT THAT TIME ONLY
LOST FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SO THIS IS IT'S
CATASTROPHIC FOR MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS. LET ME FOCUS. ON SOME
SOLUTIONS PROPOSED SOLUTIONS.
WHERE THANK CHAIRMAN RIVAS ON A
BILL BIGGEST ONE INCREASING-
GROSS VEHICLE WEIGHTS FOR TRUCKS
. WE KNOW YOU TRIED TO GET A
BILL THROUGH IT DIDN'T GO
THROUGH TO GET IT TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND WE THANK THE GOVERNOR
WHO UNTIL JUNE NOW- DOES HAVE
EIGHTY THOUSAND BUT I WANT TO
POINT OUT- SHE'S ME THAT- THE-
WASHINGTON OREGON OF INCREASED
TRUCK WEIGHTS TWO HUNDRED FIVE
THOUSAND POUNDS. WE'RE WORKING
WITH CONGRESSMAN COSTA THE
BIPARTISAN GROUP TO GET THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO INCREASE
THEIR WEIGHTS AS WELL. FOR
EXAMPLE IN RESPONSE TO KOBE
NINETEEN PROVISION IN THE CARES
ACT ALLOWED STATES TO ISSUE
PERMITS. ALLOWING TRUCKS TO
OPERATE ABOVE FEDERAL WEIGHT
LIMITS ON INTERSTATES WAIVERS
ARE ONLY AVAILABLE FOR A HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS DURING THIS TIME ONE
COMPANY WAS ABLE TO INCREASE ITS
VEHICLE CAPACITY. BY AN AVERAGE
OF TWENTY SEVEN HER MILES PER
SHIP. THIS REDUCE SHIPMENTS BY
SIX HUNDRED MILES. OURS MIGHT
REDUCE SHIPMENT BY SIX HUNDRED
MILES TRAVELED BY FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND MILES. AND REDUCE CO
TWO EMISSIONS BY A HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE. THOUSAND POUNDS. ALSO AS
MENTIONED BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER THE RECENT USDA
ANNOUNCEMENT IN HELPING- AT THE
OAKLAND PORTS WITH FUNDING CAN
WE CONTINUE TO GIVE ACT
PREFERRED ACCESS APORTES THIS
TWENTY FIVE ACRE SITE IN OAKLAND
IS SET TO OPEN IN MARCH- TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE SITE WILL PROVIDE
THE SITE UNLOAD. TO LOAD
CURRENTLY EMPTY CONTAINERS USDA
HAS AGREED TO SUBSIDIZE 60% OF
THE START UP COSTS AND PARTNER
WITH THE PORT OF OAKLAND TO
PARTIALLY COVER THE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR PER CONTAINER
REIMBURSEMENT A MAJOR SHIPPERS
AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
MENTIONED- INLAND LOAD POINTS-
CAN WE FIND AN ESTABLISHED.
INLAND LOAD POINTS ON THE WEST
COAST WHICH IS IN BAKERSFIELD
AND WEALTHY WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED WILL AMIT VALLEY. CAN
WE IDENTIFY AND FUND THOSE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE ALREADY
APPLIED FOR FUNDS AT THE STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVELS. CAN WE
EXPAND WEST COAST WEST COAST
PORT INFRASTRUCTURE. EXPEDITE
STATE AND LOCAL PERMITTING FOR
EXPANDING PORTS TO FACILITATE
EXPANSION OF TRADE AND MOVEMENT
OF CARGO. WE NEED TO INCENTIVIZE
SHIPS TO COME TO OAKLAND MANY
SHIPS CURRENTLY UNDER LOAD IN LA
AND LONG BEACH TO RETURN TO THE
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN. INSTEAD OF
GOING TO OAKLAND A LOAD AG
COMMODITIES. FOR EXAMPLE 50% OF
CALIFORNIA AG COMMODITIES GO
THROUGH THE PORT OF OAKLAND AND
WE ARE EXTREMELY PROUD OF THAT.
A VERY SUCCESSFUL URBAN AG
INTERFACE IN TERMS OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO OUR STATE ECONOMY AND
ALSO JOBS BOTH IN THE URBAN
AREAS IN A RURAL A CALIFORNIA-
OTHER COUNTRIES AS A BEEN
POINTING OUT FOR CAPITALIZING ON
OUR INABILITY TO EXPORT GOODS
FILLING THE VOID CHEAPER AND
QUICKER. BUSINESS AND TRADE WE
MAY NEVER GET BACK. CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU SUPPORTS THE FEDERAL
OCEAN SHIPPING REFORM ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A BILL BY.
CONGRESSMAN GARAMENDI AND ALSO
CONGRESSMAN- JOHNSON AT A SOUTH
DAKOTA BIPARTISAN BILL. THAT
WOULD ESTABLISH RECIPROCAL
TRADING AS WE LIKE TO STAND FARM
HERE WHETHER IT'S- RECIPROCAL
TRADER WE CAUGHT FREE TRADE.
TRADE THAT DOESN'T GO BOTH WAYS-
ISN'T REALLY TRADE- WE WILL
ESTABLISH A PHYSICAL TRAIT AS
PART OF THE FEDERAL MARITIME
COMMISSION'S MISSION PROMOTING
US EXPORTS. THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD REQUIRE OCEAN CARRIERS TO
MEET MINIMUM SERVICE STANDARDS
IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST I HOPE
YOU'LL HAVE A CHANCE IF YOU'RE
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE BILL WOULD
LOVE TO MAKE THAT AVAILABLE TO
YOU. AS WELL WE KNOW THAT
SENATOR KLOBUCHAR'S MINNESOTA'S
ALSO AGAIN INTRODUCED A BILL AS
WELL PERTAINING TO TRADE. SO HOW
DO WE ESTABLISH GREATER
RESILIENCY IN US PORTS
CALIFORNIA RELIES HEAVILY ON
IMPORTED GOODS. GOODS AS DOES
AG'S TECHNOLOGY MACHINERY
FERTILIZER SECRETARY ROSS IT
ASKED ME TO MENTION ABOUT THE
RISING COSTS I WILL POINT OUT
THAT FERTILIZER GENERALLY ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IS ABOUT 15% OF YOUR
CASH- PAYMENTS- WE'RE HEARING
REPORTS AND CERTAINLY
EXPERIENCING ON OUR FARMS-
INCREDIBLY INCREASED COST OF
FERTILIZER SOME REPORTS OVER.
THREE HUNDRED PERCENT- I ALSO
TELL YOU THAT AS WE LOOK AT NOT
ONLY A LARGE FARMS IN THE SMALL
FARMS EVERYBODY WHO HIT BY THESE
RAISING COSTS. WE ALSO HAVE TO
LOOK AT THOSE FARMERS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAYBE OPERATE ON A
CASH FLOW BASIS WHAT THIS MEANS.
IS FOR THEM WILL BE THEIR
MINIMUMS WILL GO UP IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY CAN PURCHASE AND SO
THEY WILL BE CASH STRAPPED OR
MAYBE THEY MAKE TWO OR THREE
PAYMENTS IN A YEAR WE'LL
PROBABLY HAVE TO BUY A YEAR'S
WORTH AND NOW AS WE LOOK AT
MACHINERY. THAT PURCHASING
MACHINERY THAT EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OUT NOW. ON%
THERE WILL BE CONSIDERABLE-
PRESSURE PUT ON FARMS AND
AGRICULTURE PARTICULARLY SMALLER
ONES OPERATING ON A CASH FLOW-
ALSO- CAN WE DELAY ENFORCEMENT
OF NEW FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
AMERICAN TRUCK DRIVERS AS WE
TALKED ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY
TRUCK DRIVERS. FEBRUARY SEVENTH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR THE
FIRST TIME WILL BEGIN REQUIRING
THAT ALL NEW COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S
LICENSE APPLICANTS. BE TRAINED
AND REGISTERED FACILITY. HOW
WILL THAT DO FOR REGISTRY WILL
AT. GETTING DRIVERS TRAINED OR
WILL IT SLOW THE PROCESS DOWN
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO. KEEP
OUR EYE ON AND ASK FOR SOMETHING
TO BE A MODIFIED. AND LET'S
ESTABLISH FIXED WINDOWS SUPPORT
ACCESS TO AVOID SCHEDULING
CONFLICTS AND CONFUSION. THIS IS
AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM THAT AFFECTS
CALIFORNIANS IN THE OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT WE FEED. AROUND
THE WORLD THE UNITED STATES IS
THE BIGGEST AG EXPORTER IN THE
WORLD. IN THIS PAST YEARHANDS
ARE COMPLETELY TIED BY THE
EFFECTS OF THIS GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
WITH CURRENT LABOR ISSUES THAT
NOT ONLY AFFECT PORT ACCESS AND
EFFICIENCY BUT ALSO A DRIVER
SHORTAGE THAT AFFECTS. MOVEMENT
OF PRODUCTS TO THESE PORTS
CURRENTLY FREIGHT LINERS ARE
ALLOWED TO LEAVE U. S. PORTS
WITH EMPTY CONTAINERS. NOT
WILLING TO WAIT FOR EXPORTING
GOODS SINCE THE US IS BEING
OUTBID BY COMPETING. EXPORTERS
OVERSEAS. CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
GOODS ARE THEN LEFT TO ROT WHILE
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE INCREASING
THEIR AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS TO
FILL THE VOID. THERE'S NOT ONE
SOLUTION TO THIS MULTIPLE
PRONGED MULTI PRONGED ISSUE. THE
CALIFORNIA CAN HELP IMPLEMENT
SMALL CHANGES IN ORDER TO START
LEADING SOME OF THE EXTERNAL
PRESSURES. ON AGRICULTURE THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT
TESTIMONY MISTER JOHNSON IF.
THANK WITH YOUR HANDS WERE NEXT
GOING TO MISS GOING TO OCCUR DAY
HAY SEUSS EASTPORT DIRECTOR OF
THE PORT OF STOCKTON. AND WHAT I
NEED TO GET OUT TO THE PORT OF
STOCKTON AND NEVER BEEN THERE
ARE DRIVEN BY IT. AND SOME
OTHERS IN THIS ROOM NEED TO GET
OUT TO THE BOARD OF STOCKTON
THAT DOESN'T COUNT DRIVE BYS DO
NOT COUNT MISTER VEHICLE IT BILL
IS GOING TO. GIVE US A TOUR OF
THE PORT OF STOCKTON WITH THE
STAFF THERE SHORTLY I HOPE. AND
AFTERWARDS HE'LL BUY US LUNCH
HE'S OFFERED TO DO THAT AS WELL.
SO WITH THAT- MISTER TO HAY
SEUSS FROM THE PORT OF STOCKTON. AND WHEN YOU ARE READY TO
RETHINK YOU. THANKS FOR TIME
AFTER. THAT AND- ANYONE IS
WELCOME AND WILL. WE BE LUNCH SO
. JUST A QUICK INTRO ONCE THE
PORT STOCKTON SINCE MANY PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT- WEREN'T
IMPORT AS MENTIONED SEVEN MILES
INLAND. WE HAVE TWO THOUSAND
OPERATIONAL ACRES. FOURTEEN
BIRTHS SEVENTY FIVE MILES OF
RAIL TRACK. ONE COURT PROPERTY-
LAST WEEK FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION METRIC TONS OF CARGO
WHICH MAKES US THE FOURTH.
BUSIEST CALIFORNIA COURT- AS FAR
AS RUSSELL CALLS GO. OUR PRIMARY
FOCUS IS BREAK BOOK. IN BOOK WE
DO HAVE THE CAPACITY. IN THE
OPERATIONAL ABILITY TO MOVE
CONTAINERS. AND ALL TALK ABOUT
THAT THE SECOND- WE CAN BE OF
SOLUTION MEMORY. SINCE WE ARE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE SHOULD BE
OF THE SOLUTION- AGAIN HAVE THE
- TO HANDLE THE DISH BREAK BOOK
INTO TEARS. LOOK AFTER ABOUT-
FOR SOME OF THE CONTAINER.
CONTAINER STORE IS AN ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN I DON'T TRUST
CRISTINA TALK ABOUT THE EARLIER
- WE HAVE TO GO CARGO OWNERS. TO
THINK- NEXT AG EXPO GONNA BUT
THEY CURRENTLY BACK- TO BREAK
BOX FORM JUST BECAUSE WE'RE BILL
BIT THE AND COST- WHAT WE'VE
SEEN AND WE'RE SEEING IT MORE ON
THE IMPORT SIDE FROM ASIA TO THE
US MARKET WE LAST WEEK TWENTY
FOUR VESSEL CALLS A COMMODITY
THAT WOULD NORMALLY BE IN
CONTAINERS- THAT IS MOVING BREAK
BALK- BY THE END OF NEXT MONTH
WE SHOULD SEE FIFTEEN BUSTLE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT 20%
INCREASE. IN VESSEL CALLS YEAR
OVER YEAR SO WE EXPECT THAT
TREND TO CONTINUE OBVIOUSLY MOST
THE CARGO. WE THINK WHEN THIS
SITUATION. RELAXES FIRST LICENSE
WE SEE THAT CARGO TO. BUTSOME
OF IT'S GOING TO PERSONALLY
SHIFTED IN WALK SO. THE TREND
LIKE THAT SAID THAT WAS ASIA TO
US WEST COAST MARKETS FOR IMPORT
CARGOES WERE STEEP RECEIVING
MORE AND MORE INTEREST IN-
EXPORTS- AS I SAID WE ARE
CONTAINERIZED HE- WE'RE NOT
AUTHORIZED CBP TO CLEAR
CONTAINERIZED CARGO FROM AN
IMPORT. SIDE BUT WE ARE
OPERATIONALLY READY TO HANDLE
THAT- IN WEEK COULD HANDLE
EXPORTCARGO IN CONTAINERS
TODAY- AGAIN WERE RECEIVING A
BRIEF WORKING WITH QUITE A FEW
DIFFERENT CUSTOMERS ON MAKING
THIS HAPPEN- ONE THING FOR THE
IMPORT. TASK FORCE CONTAINERS GO
CDP SUPPORT FOR THIS CONTAINER
SCANNING THE PORT IS IT'S
CRITICAL- NECESSARY AND
CRITICAL. THE THING THAT WE SEE
WITH THIS IT WOULD BE SMALLER
VESSELS OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OUR
DRAFT SO WE'RE LOOKING AT TWO
THOUSAND T. E. USE BUT ANY
CONTAINER WE HANDLED ORDER
STOCKTON. S. POST SENATE- FOR
THE WAY. IS TAKING A TRUCK OFF
ROAD SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
THE AND JUST ALONG THE. FIVE
EIGHTY. IT IS AN SO I THINK THE
BIGGEST THING TO GET OUT OF
COURSE NOW AWARENESS THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO HANDLE THESE COMMODITIES
AND- WITH IT AND AGAIN CHANGING
THE THINKING. ON HOW THESE
COMMODITIES ARE HANDLED EITHER
GRATEFUL OR SMALL VESSEL EXPORTS
ARE OF COURSE TALKING. THANKS
FOR YOUR RETREATED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING OUT OF THE PORT OF
STOCKTON. YEAH ANY TIME LIKE I
SAID RIGHT- WITH THAT I WILL GO
TO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
pTO THE LAST PANEL- ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MR
FONG. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
ACTUALLY A QUESTION- THE FOR JB
HERE- IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT- CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
FARMERS LOST AN ESTIMATED TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
EXPORT SALES BETWEEN MAY AND
SEPTEMBER LAST YEAR DO THE
CONGESTIONS- WHICH CERTAINLY IS
A THREAT TO THE STATE'S ECONOMIC
VIABILITY IS THERE UPDATED
NUMBERS- I KNOW THAT WE'VE HEARD
A NUMBER OF. A PANELIST BUT
BROADLY I MEAN IS THERE IS THERE
AN ESTIMATED NUMBER OF. LOSSES
SINCE THEN- I HAVEN'T HEARD OF
THE NUMBERS OF WHAT WE'RE
HEARING THE WHAT WE'RE HEARING
THAT WHEN THE NUMBERS DO COME
OUT I'M SURE- THE GENTLEMAN FROM
THE PORT OF OAKLAND- WOULD-
KNOWING CERTAINLY AT THE SONOMA
AS WELL BUT THAT AT DECEMBER
WILL BE PROBABLY PROBABLY THE
WORST MONTH. ON RECORD AND THAT
ALSO TO THOSE NUMBERS THE TWO
POINT ONE BILLION WAS JUST
BETWEEN I BELIEVE MAY AND
SEPTEMBER SO YOU ALSO HAVE TO
FACTOR IN OCTOBER NOVEMBER. AND
DECEMBER WHEN WE GET THOSE
NUMBERS SO FROM A TREND
STANDPOINT IT'S NOT GETTING ANY
BETTER I THINK IT'S GETTING ANY
BETTER ONE OF THE LARGEST DAIRY
EXPORTERS- RECENTLY- A SAID THAT
90% OF HIS EXPORT ORDERS ARE NOW
GOING ON FIELD HE'S LARGEST
DAIRY EXPORTER. I BELIEVE IN
AMERICA- DOING OF AMONG OTHER
THINGS MOZZARELLA CHEESE USUALLY
COMING OUT OF THE WEST PORTS BUT
NOW. PIVOTING THE SOUTHEASTERN
PORTS SUCH AS IN SHREVEPORT- AND
HE DOES NOT SEE RECOVERING- HIS
EXPORT HIS ABILITY GOING BACK TO
WHERE IT WAS FOR EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. THANK YOU
AND I JUST- LOCAL LAST QUESTION-
TO DANNY AND KIRK- THE
CERTAINLY- IT WAS MENTIONED
BEFORE THE NEED TO ENCOURAGE
SHIPPERS TO- TAKE BACK- FULL
CONTAINERS I LOOK FORWARD TO
VISITING BOTH THE POOR STOCKTON
AND- AND THE PORT OF OAKLAND-
AND THEN OF COURSE THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF FOCUS ON LIKE
MODERNIZING. FOCUSING ON
DIGITALIZATION INFORMATION
SHARING WHAT SPECIFICALLY CAN BE
DONE AT YOUR PORTS TO FACILITATE
THAT AS WELL AS- MAKE. SHIPPERS
TAKE BACK FULL CONTAINERS. UP
OKAY I WILL START COULD YOU
UPGRADE ANY YEAH SO- I THINK I
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN TERMS THE
TEMPORARY POP UP THE ART IS ONE
OF THOSE MEASURES WERE TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE TO PROVIDE TO SPACE
THE TIME TO ADDRESS BASIN TIME
YOU QUIT THAT. TO BOTH- I HAVE
TO TAKE IT OFF THE DRUM ROLLS TO
PROBATE TO PROVIDE MORE ROOM AND
MORE TIME SO THAT- THE-
SHIPPERS. I CAN SEE THAT THEIR
CAPACITY THAT THEY CAN MOVE THAT
. ASK THEN IF THERE WAS A CROWD
CONDITION AT THE POOL. AND THAT
WE COMMUTER. IS POPPING UP CUT
USED THE SHIPPING LINES. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THIS
IS TO ASSIST THEM. TO MOVE THE
CONTAINERS FASTER SO THAT
THEY'RE MORE WILLING TO DO ALL
AT PORTABLE OAKLAND YOU WANNA
TAKE THOSE EXPORTS AND FILL THE
CONTAINERS AND TAKE IT BACK TO
ASIA. RATHER THAN TRY AND RATHER
THAN DECIDING BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO WAIT TO SIMPLY CALL BACK
ASIA QUICKLY. SO THAT IS ONE OF
THOSE HINGS OU CAN DO ON THE
ILLINOIS SIDE AND ON THAT SIDE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
CONGESTION NEW INTERNOS AROUND
QUICKLY SO THAT THE SHIPPING
LINES DON'T LOSE MONEY I GIVE
THEIR VIEW. BY WAITING TOO LONG. FOR THE EXPORTS TO BE LOADED.
YOU'RE FROM POOREST. SO THINK
IT'S LOGISTIC QUESTION
IMMEDIATELY GET INTO CONTAINERS
HERE TO CENTRAL VALLEY. WHERE
THE COMMODITY IS WHERE THE ACT
COMMODITY IS. NOT GETTING A
LOADED HERE AND THEN GETTING
THEM TO REALIZE THAT WE CAN'T
SEND THIS- THE CONTAINERS
OUTBOUND. FROM THE PORT OF
STOCKTON- SMALLER BATCH SO
OBVIOUSLY- AND THAT WAY WE CAN
ALLEVIATE THE TRAFFIC FLOW ON ON
FIVE EIGHTY BUT REALLY THAT THE
ISSUE FOR US I THINK IS. THE
AVAILABILITY OF EMPTY CONTAINERS
AFTER AT THE SOURCE OF THE
ORIGIN. SO IF I CAN ASK ONE LAST
QUESTION IN IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU
GUYS ARE EXPERIENCING WHAT IT
MAKES SENSE THEN TO. I KNOW
THERE WAS DISCUSSIONS IN THE
LAST QUARTER WE HAD ABOUT
IDENTIFYING OTHER. INLAND PORTS
OR INLAND FACILITIES TO KIND OF
RELIEVE PRESSURE- WHICH OF
COURSE YOU'RE DOING- IT IT SEEMS
LIKE IN THE- BORDER STOCKTON
WITH WHAT WAS ANNOUNCED. SHOULD
SHOULD THAT BE REPLICATED- IN.
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE- YOU
KNOW BUYING THE POOR IN. SUCH A
VALLEY OR AND- THEY'LL VALLEY.
BELIEVING PRESSURE OFF LONG
BEACH AND LOS ANGELES- YOU KNOW.
IN THE SHORT TERM WOULD THAT BE.
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE-
YES SO TO- TO FACILITATE
EVERYTHING. WHY BACK DIRECTORS
WHOSE IN MY AND JUST TALKING
ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY IN FACT-
JUST BETWEEN THE PORT OF OAKLAND
AND PORT IT- STOCKTON- THERE
COULD BE SYNERGIES BETWEEN US IF
WE COULD ESTABLISH THAT RAIL
LINK BETWEEN THE TWO PORTS. THAT
CERTAINLY WE COULD- MAKE SURE
THAT THE US DIRECTOR ISSUE SAYS
THAT THEY ARE AWARE THERE'S
DIFFERENT MODES OF. EXPORTING
THE ABNORMALITIES BUT ALSO- TO
HAVE RESTOCKED IN SUPPORT
INTERNS ARE TAKING A RELIEF OFF
OF THE ROLLS AND HIGHWAYS THIS
CALL. QUE NO SPACE IN THE INLAND
PORT CONCEPT SO THAT CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT- WE WOULD HOPE
THAT HE- THE STATE WOULD HELP US
INVEST. IN YOU MISTER PRODUCT IS
THE MACAW HERE. IF YOU KNOW AND
- WHICH IS THEY IF THE GOAL IS
TO X. GOODS. RIGHT BE THE
AGRICULTURAL OR IN PRODUCTS OR
OTHER BECAUSE LOT OF IT WE'RE
TALKING A LOT ABOUT TODAY. BUT
THERE'S A MACHINE READ THIS MAN
CALIFORNIA AND THE WEST THAT
ALSO GOES ON OUR PORCH IS A LOT
THAT THAT'S EXPORT BUT OF THE
GOAL IS TO. IS TO EXPORT I MEAN
ENCOURAGE ENCOURAGEMENT IS GOOD
BUT A POLICY IS BETTER. AND I
WAS JUST CONVERSING WITH ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES HERE WHERE MAYBE
WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT-
REQUIRING- INSIDE THE PORT
CONFERENCE RIGHT THEY SIGNED THE
LEASE AS THEIR LITTLE THEY ARE
THEY'RE- THEY'RE- THEY'RE
LESSORS. THAT WHEN THEY SIGNED
THEIR LEASES THE PORTS DO WITH
WITH THE PERSON IS LEASING. THE
TERMINAL. THAT THEY DO HAVE.
SOME TYPE OF- EXPORT
REQUIREMENTS I WOULDN'T WANT TO
BE TOO PRESCRIPTIVE. I THINK WE
NEED TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT THAT
AND TO HAVE A LOT OF INPUT IS
WHETHER OR NOT THAT BUT IT WOULD
BE WISE BUT IT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING WE SHOULD THINK OF.
WEARING AGAIN- THERE IS SOME
ONUS ON SOME LEVERAGE. ON THE
TERMINAL OPERATORS TO HAVE- IN
EXPORT COMPONENT. AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT WOULD LARA YOU
NEED TO BE CAREFUL- THE WEEDY
AGAIN WE DON'T WANT TO COMMAND-
THE TERMINALS TO DO ANYTHING
BECAUSE LEGALLY THAT PROBABLY
WOULDN'T HOLD UP ANYWAYS IS
INTERSTATE COMMERCE A LOT. AND
IS A PRIVATE RELATIONSHIPS WE
DON'T WANT TO DELVE INTO THAT
TOO MUCH. BUT AGAIN IT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING TO DO SO THAT WE CAN
LEVERAGE. IN ORDER TO GET. MORE
MORE EXPORTS BECAUSE PORT SIDE
WERE ALREADY. STATE AND ANNA
THIS. I WOULD SAY THAT- YOU KNOW
I WANT I WANT TO COMMEND YOU
DEAD- AS YOUR DONALD MEAN
CERTAINLY YOU SAID THIS IS OUR
LAST HEARING. WE NEED TO HAVE A
SENSE OF URGENCY. AND I THINK
THAT- I AGREE I AGREE WITH YOU
MORE AND- I THINK CERTAINLY WE
DON'T WANT TO AFFECT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR INTERACTIONS. THE MARKET-
YOU KNOW. WE WANT ENSURE THE-MARKET- FUNCTIONS AND SO- AND
ALLOW THE FREE MARKET SUIT TO
PLAY ITSELF OUT SO. I CERTAINLY
THINK THERE NEEDED TO POLICY
CHANGES IS CERTAINLY- SO ACTED
BY- WHAT WITH THE FIVE YEARS
SAID. AND BUT I THINK WE ARE
CALLING FROM FROM FROM FROM
STOCK IN A COLLEAGUES WINTERS.
YEAH WE'RE HEARING IT. FROM OUR
AGRICULTURAL- INDUSTRY IN OUR
FARMERS ISRAEL. HAD A
CONSEQUENCES ARE ARE BUILDING UP
AND WE NEED TO ACT- AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE SO WHATEVER WE NEED
TO DO. IN TERMS OF INVESTMENTS
WHATEVER WE DO IN TERMS OF
MODERNIZATION WHATEVER WE NEED
TO DO. TO FACILITATE- THESE INTO
CONTAINERS LEAVING IN A FULL
CONTAINERS GOING. AND WE NEED TO
DO THAT AND AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SO THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT. RIGHT MISTER VIA
PUT. NUMBER ON. OKAY AS
AGUIAR-CURRY. THERE'S SO MUCH I
COULD ASK TODAY- POLICE TO BRING
TO THE SIR- HAVE A FOR THOSE OF
US IN THE AMERICAN UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON IT'S VERY VERY
FRUSTRATING- BUT YOU KNOW I DID
HAVE A QUESTION I WANTED TO ASK
IN IS LIKE DOES ANYONE TO THEIR
KNOWLEDGE- NO- WHEN CALIPH
CALIFORNIA IMPORTERS ALSO
SUBJECT TO UNFAIR DETENTION
DEMURRAGE CHARGES. AS RESULT OF
OCEAN KERRIER ACTIONS I MEAN WE
COULD GET GETTING THESE FEES-
WHEN TRYING TO EXPORT OR SITTING
IN SOME JUST WHEN DO THE
IMPORTERS GET THAT SIMPLY. YES
YES THEY ARE THE MERGERS OF PLY
TO BOTH. IT'S NOT WHETHER YOUR
EMPLOYER EXPORTER IT'S HOW LONG
YOU DO OUT ON THE PORCH. UNDER
TRUMP SPACE. THE SUCH AND FEAR-
ANYWAY SO I JUST FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE PEOPLE WHO CAME TO
SPEAK TODAY AND WE HEARD YOU BUT
I REALLY WISH YOU WULD HAVE HAD
MORE TIME FOR YOU TO ASK MORE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I THINK WE
SHOULD OF- ASKED TO SOME VERY
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS AS WELL AS
HOUSES AFFECTING YOUR FAMILIES
YOUR YOU KNOW THE FARMS- WHAT'S
PESTS WE HAD TO PASS IT YOU PUT
IN THE PAST AND ISSUES LIKE THAT
I MEAN I WAS GOING TO ASK ABOUT
DISEASE AN INCREASE. ON THE
ASPECT OF IMPACTS ON YOUR
BUSINESS I MEAN ALL THESE THINGS
WE DIDN'T GET ASKED TODAY SHOULD
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE THESE I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS
IS GOING TO WORK- BUT I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
URGENCY- PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE ON
THE- LINE HERE THERE'S PRODUCTS
SITTING IN WAREHOUSES JUST
SITTING THERE THE PRICES ARE
GOING DOWN IT THE CALIFORNIA
BRAND WE ARE SO PROUD OF THE
CALIFORNIA BRANCH. WHEN YOU
CAN'T PUT IT ON THE OUTSIDE OF
HIS UP RICE BAGS OR IS NOT
PREVENTING IT WOULD JUST IT JUST
MAKES MORE ECONOMICAL SENSE TO
SEND THEM DIFFERENTLY SO I JUST
THINK THAT WE NEED TO- A REALLY
A BIG KNOWLEDGE WHAT'S GOING ON
AND I THINK MAYBE WE CAN HAVE
SOME POLICY COME OUT OF THIS I
KNOW I'M WORKING ON SOME I THINK
OTHERS ARE AS WELL. ARAMBULA FIX
THIS RIGHT AWAY I WISH I COULD
SAY YES BUT I THINK WE AS A TEAM
NEED TO WORK ON THIS AND MAKE
SURE IT'S URGENT YEAH I THINK I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT IS A CALIFORNIA EXPORT
POLICY I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
THERE IS ONE. NO ONE BROUGHT ONE
UP TODAY SO MAYBE IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON US TO CREATE ONE AND UNDER
THAT UMBRELLA MANY THINGS FALL
COULD BE INFRASTRUCTURE IT CAN
BE POLICIES WITH REGARD TO
EXPORTS ON THE DOCK CETERA SO-
THOSE ARE THE CONVERSATIONS.
WE'LL BE HAVING GOING FORWARD.
JEFF QUICKLY BY THE L. IS ON A
CALL I SIT ON THE- FOR THE- AND
RURAL. SO IT'S ALL ALL THE GUYS
ARE. THE AND THE CAN. PROVINCES
ACTUALLY JUST TALKING ABOUT THIS
LAST WEEK. OUR CALL THERE ABOUT
. YOU KNOW IT THAT THEY'RE
BEATEN ME UP THEY'RE GOING DEVON
WHAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
CALIFORNIA WHAT'S UP WITH YOUR
PORTS- SO THIS ISN'T JUST.
CALIFORNIA AG THIS'S NATIONALLY
THIS IS ALL OF THESE. FAMILIES
IS OUR OUR COLLEAGUE MISTER
VILAKKU LAW MENTION WE HAVE
GENERATIONAL FAMILIES THAT ARE
LOOKING AT THIS GOING WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THIS. THIS DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE AND IT'S
HEARTBREAKING TO HEAR THIS
BECAUSE I HEAR IT FROM. THAT THE
FOLKS. IN MY BACKYARD. IT IS
WERE PLANNING THE WORLD AG EXPO
. COMING UP IN MY DISTRICT I
DON'T WANT TO BE ON THE GROUND
THERE HEARING THAT- THIS IS
SOMETHING WE DO HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT THE CONVERSATION IS GREAT
AND IT'S DIRE. AND I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY BEING HERE I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS- CONTINUE
EFFORT I DO LOOK AT I THINK
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO LUNCH ON
MISTER PHILLIPS WOULD WALK DOWN
AND STOCKTON- WE GOT TO GET THIS
FIGURED OUT AND I'M OPEN TO WHAT
WHATEVER POLICY DRIVERS WE NEED
TO DO. AT THE SAME TIME WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
PUSHING TOO HARD- ON THE MARKET
IN BEING TOO ONEROUS- BUT
THERE'S A LOT THAT'S GOTTA GET
DONE I GOTTA GET DONE QUICKLY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU ANY ANY FURTHER YET
SO WE YEAH AND SO I- OBVIOUSLY
WANT TO THANK- THE CHAIRMAN-
DONALD. ALL OF- THE MEMBERS
LEGISLATURE THAT WERE HERE WANT
TO THANK OUR PANELISTS- WE DO
HAVE TO MOVE MOVE UP FOR US
PUBLIC COMMENT SO IF THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE COMMENTS NOW
IS THE TIME TO DO SO. THE SCENE
AT NINE- WILL GO WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES A MODERATOR IF-
THERE ARE- ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC- THAT ONE FIVE COMMENTS
IF THEY ARE IN THE QUEUE- PLEASE
OPEN UP FOR THE FIRST CALLER.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NINE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE AND PLACE IT BACK INTO
THE QUEUE. SO AGAIN ARE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE'LL BEGIN WITH LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MR
MODERATOR A ONE MINUTE.
COMMITTEE EACH CALLER MISTER
MODERATOR ONE MINUTE EACH HI MY
COMMITTEE IF THEY'RE WAY OFF
TOPIC PLEASE MOVE TO THE NEXT
CALLER. HARTLINE COMMITTEE I AM
WE ARE WE CAN HEAR YOU YES. OH
GREAT I'M GLAD YOU'RE HAVING
PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY THAT ISN'T
ALWAYS TE CASE SO I'M CALLING
OF THE SOON TO BE EX CALIFORNIA
I AM A SMALL SCALE DAIRY GOAT
FARMER AND LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE
DECIDING TO LEAVE THE STATE. I
AM ACTIVELY TAKING STEPS TO MOVE
MY FAMILY OF SIX TO FLORIDA IN A
NUTSHELL FLORIDA'S NOT HAVING
ANY OF THE PROBLEMS THAT YOU
HAVE DESCRIBED TODAY AND THAT'S
THE REALITY THAT CALIFORNIANS
ARE FLEEING THIS FAILED STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT IS AMAZING TO
HEAR YOU LAWMAKERS TALK ABOUT
THE SHORTAGE OF PORT WORKERS AND
TRUCK DRIVERS WITHOUT EVEN
MENTIONING THE EIGHTY FIVE
KILLED THE INDEPENDENT TRUCKING
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA TO HEAR
THESE SUPPOSED EXPERTS DRONE ON
AND ON ABOUT THE FUTURE OF ZERO
EMISSIONS IN AG IS MIND NUMBING.
SPEAKING OF THE FARMER ONE OF
THE LAST TIME YOU SAW AN
ELECTRIC OR SOLAR TRACTOR AND
DESPITE WHAT YOU THINK SIMPLY
MANDATING FARM EQUIPMENT TO BE
NON FOSSIL FUEL BASED DOES NOT
MAGICALLY MAKE IT HAPPEN AND NOW
YOU IN THE GOVERNOR ARE
MANDATING THE SHOTS TO BRING
ABOUT MORE WORKER SHORTAGES. ARE
YOU PEOPLE NOT PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE TRUCK DRIVERS THAT
BASICALLY HELPED OTTAWA CANADA
COMPLETELY NOW I. DO TO THE
FOUGHT ABOUT FASHION MANDATE SO-
DONALD PRISON LONG FONG FORGOT.
AND LEGAL ENJOYED CRAFT MY DO
YOU CAN GO NEXT CALLER THANK YOU
COMES. ABSOLUTE WE WILL GO TO
FIFTH PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR GOOD
MORNING BURNING COMMITTEE JR OF
AFFAIRS FOR HELP TRUCKERS. I
WANTED THANK CHAIR WITH AND SOME
OF THEM ROAD OVER HIGHLY THE
ISSUE FACING OUR CRITICAL AG AND
ACT. THANK YOU BY THE WAY THIS
IS TODAY ARE CERTAIN INVESTMENTS
TERM ABOUT NEED IN OUR HIMFOR.
TO ACCOMMODATE GROWING CARGO
VOLUMES BUT ALSO MANY CHALLENGES
FACING BOTH AGRICULTURAL
EXPORTERS AND CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS MANUFACTURERS WITH
RESPECT TO INCREASE COSTS AND
CHARGES FOR CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH
ARE OUT OF THE CONTROL. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DIALOGUE WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
THIS ISSUE I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN
FOR THE LEADERSHIP ON. CONVENING
THIS HEARING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING MARC NEXT PLEASE
. REAL GOOD OVER LINE NINETEEN
YOUR OPEN. 381-919-1919 NINETEEN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE I REMEMBER
I REMEMBER. BOB LAZAR FOR ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO- A PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. ONE FILED
BY ZERO. AND AS A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE THEY WERE GETTING A
COUPLE WE WILL GO TO LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD BY BUT
BUT BUT HE- YOU. I HAD A TRIED
NINETEEN AGAIN I'M SORRY OF ALL
IT'S THE DEAL THEY'RE LIABLE
GALAI TWENTY YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD TWENTY. HELLO I'M
TWENTY YES GREAT THANK YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
OKAY GREAT A GOOD MORNING SURE
ENSURE MEMBERS I'M SORRY- WE'RE
TO TAKE A LITTLE WALK DOWN
MEMORY LANE AND WORDS OF ANDREW
NEARING IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
IN THE SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND
TWO- THAT- AND RDC ANNA AND
OTHER SEVERAL LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVIST GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA PUSH FOR THE RADICAL
AGENDA TO COMBAT THE DROUGHT IN
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE MOVING ONE
POINT THREE MILLION ACRES OF
FARMLAND. FROM DEDUCTIONS AND
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. THE
EFFORT TO MESSAGE BACK AMOUNT OF
. FROM TURKEY PRODUCTION.
BECAUSE MANY MANY ISSUES AND THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. WE NEED TO
GET BACKGROUND FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO EXPAND FARMLANDS
WE ARE LOSING HOMES RIGHT NOW I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS ARE AWARE
OF THAT. HOW MUCH MORE OUR
CULTURE WE GOING TO LOSE BEFORE
WE REALIZED WE NEED TO STORE
MORE WATER. FORCE AS SOMEONE
DROUGHT SO BECOMING. AN EX I DO
WANT TO SAY I APPRECIATE THE-
MENTION OF REIMBURSING. THE COST
OF CONTAINERS THE WIRE WE NOT
MAKING CONTAINERS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES. THAT WOULD BE
MORE COST EFFECTIVE THAN TRYING
TO GET THEM IMPORTED RIGHT NOW-
WHERE'S THE MONEY GOING I MEAN
AND EN WHO CAN BE PAYING FOR
THIS IS THERE GOING TO BE THE
TAXPAYERS ARE GOING TO RECEIVE
MORE TALK. FOR THE FOR THE
REIMBURSED FROM THE THERE DO YOU
MEAN I DO A PRE THAT BUT I THINK
WE NEED TO BE FOCUSING MORE ON
MADE IN USA PRODUCTS. I MEAN
SIMPLY AND SIMPLY JUST AND IT
MANDATES- TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK AND I THINK IT WOULD SOLVE
A LOT OF OUR ISSUES RIGHT NOW.
RESHAPE LEAFLETS. TO AND I HOPE
YOU GUYS TAKE THE SUSAN GOOD.
AND HAVE A GOOD AFTER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY OTHER CALLERS. NOT AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. A. N.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT AGAIN
APPRECIATE TO ALL THE PANELISTS
AND THOSE THAT WERE INTENSELY
DAY IN VIEWING FROM HOME- AND-
THAT CONCLUDES HERE HAVE A
GREAT. DAY REST OF THE WEEK.